GOOD MORNING -- WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE --
BEFORE I BEGIN -- WE NEED
TO READ THE FOLLOWING
WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE HEARING BY VISITING
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AT
H. T. T. P. S. ASSEMBLY
COLON DASH DASH A. P. S. S.
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOP BACKSLASH PLEASE NOTE
THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEES
CONSIDERED PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAYBE READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED ALL ARE ENCOURAGED
TO WATCH THE HEARINGS FROM
ITS LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE AT W.
W. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOV BACKSLASH TODAY'S
EVENT THE HEARING ROOM WILL
BE OPEN FOR ATTENDANCE AT
THIS HEARING ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC ATTENDING A HEARING
IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK
AT ALL TIMES WHILE IN THE
BUILDING THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING
BY TELEPHONE WE ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR UPDATES
IN ORDER TO RESEARCH PASILA
TAKE THE GOAL OF HEARING AS
MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN THE
LIMITS OF OUR TIME WE WILL NOT
PERMIT CONTACTED DISRUPTS --
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS PLEASE BE AWARE
THAT BY LEGIONS OF THESE RULES
MAYES SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS
-- AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE
WAITING TO GET A
WITNESS WHO AUTHOR
AND WE'RE ALSO WAITING
FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO ATTEND MISTER SEA ARE
TOO HIGH OUR LOWLY
HELLO
WHERE THE ON TIME CLUB
IN
IN ADDITION WE HAVE
BOB VOTE ONLY ITEMS ALL
VOTE ONLY ITEMS WILL
BE DISPENSED WITH AT
THE END OF THE HEARING
THIS IS YOUR
IS A UNIQUELY OFFERS
AS A FIRST LINE ORDER
THERE ARE
THANK YOU
SIR THE REMOVAL
HELLO EVERYONE EVEN IF YOU WANT
OKAY
SIX ZERO SEVEN DISTANCE
AND TRY TO GET OVER HERE MR
COOPER SUBSIDIES AS WE HEAR
REPLY FROM THE EAST COAST
MR CRIME OFFICE THIS
OR -- THEY SAID THEY'RE ON
THEIR WAY THIS COURSE WAS ENDING
IN WITH RECENT STUFF YOU SEE
YESTERDAY OUR
SO
RIGHT
BERMAN FOR
WE NOW HAVE A SURPRISE
THREE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT ARE HERE WAITING TO GET A
QUORUM WE NEED TO MORE MEMBERS
WHAT
ABOUT THAT
SHORTLY
YES I
GOOD MORNING SINCE YOU'RE
HERE MISTER COOPER WHY DON'T
YOU HAVE A SEAT AND PRESENT
FIRST -- WORK WORK WHEN IT
AS A SUB COMMITTEE DO THAT
THE WAY FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TWO TO TEN SO YOUR ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTEEN COOPER -- THAT
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSUS -- CURRENT LAW
ALLOWS FOR UNCHECKED SERIAL
THEFT WITHOUT REAL CONSEQUENCES
AND PROMOTES CONOVER HAGER FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO REPEAL THE
STILL ITEMS UNDER THE RETAIL
THRESHOLD OF NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS FOR THE MORE THE SAYS
THE RETAIL PROPERTY UNDER NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS CANNOT
BE AGGREGATED BY THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT REGARDLESS OF THE TIME
AND DISTANCE BETWEEN EACH
OFFENSE THIS IS LED TO A SURGE
IN THEFTS WERE SHOPLIFTER STILL
MULTIPLE TIMES IN A DAY FROM
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS VOTERS A
NOTICE A SURGE IN SERIAL RETAIL
CRIME RECENT UC BERKELEY POLL
COSPONSORED BY THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES SURVEYED VOTERS ON THE
IMPACT OF CEREAL FOR RETAIL
THEFT AND FOUND THAT SEVENTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS CITY THINK CRIME HAS
RISEN STATEWIDE OVER THE LAST
YEAR TWO ONE SUPPORT FOR
REFORMING PROP FORTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT THE CRIME IS
INCREASED LOCALLY FIFTY NINE
PERCENT SUPPORT CHANGING PROP
FORTY SEVEN TO LESSER PROPERTY
CRIMES BE PROSECUTED AGAIN
AS FELONIES AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTEEN WILL CREATE A WOBBLER
FOR THE THIRD CONVICTION OF
RETAIL THEFT OVER FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A CONVICTION WILL BE
SUBJECT TO SENTENCING IN COUNTY
JAIL ONLY BE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
DOES NOT RECALL PROP FORTY
SEVEN A MUST GO TO VOTE AND MUST
GO TO VOTERS FOR THE APPROVAL
IT SAID AGAIN A. B. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DOES NOT REPEAL PROP
FORTY SEVEN AND MUST GO TO THE
VOTERS FOR APPROVAL THANK
YOU YES
-- DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE IN THE ROOM RIGHT
NOW ARE YOU WITNESSES
OUTSIDE THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
THEY WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN COOPER
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
AND ONE MOMENT AS WE GET LINE
NUMBERS ONCE AGAIN THAT IS
ONE ZERO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO SEVEN ONE EIGHT
SO FAR FIRST WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
TURN MEMBERS THAT JUST HAD
ONE MORE PHONE ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU
WE HAVE LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD THE MORNING
TURN MEMBERS ONLY DEALT IN
THE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNIQUE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU
AND THAT IS ALL I HAD TO KEEP
IT WILL NOW GO FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM I HAVE MARGO GEORGE
TESTIFIED IN PERSON HEY MIKE A
-- I'M SORRY ED LITTLE I'M
SORRY A LITTLE AND AND --
WHEN MY MISTAKE
AND THE SURVEY
IT WHEN FROM INSIDE
GARDEN PROGRAM BECAUSE WE
TESTIFYING IN PERSON SO --
YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING SHARED
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS A LITTLE
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE AND I RESPECTFULLY
COME BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTEEN FOR FORTY SEVEN
HAS BEEN EXPLICIT EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL IN CALIFORNIA AND
VOTERS SHOULD BE VERY PROUD
OF WHAT THEY'VE ACHIEVED AND
ACTING IN EIGHT YEARS AGO
PROP FORTY SEVEN IS SAVE THE
STATE NEARLY SIX HUNDRED MILLION
AND PRISON BECAUSE THEY'RE BY
REDIRECTING FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
TO PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSES OF CRIME VIOLENCE IN
ALLOCATING MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
MILLION TO TRAUMA RECOVERY AND
SCHOOL BASED PROGRAMS AS MANY AS
FORTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S HAVE
RECEIVE SUBSTANCE USE MENTAL
HEALTH OR HOUSING SERVICES
THROUGH PROP FORTY SEVEN FIND
A PROGRAM'S PARTICIPANTS IN
THIS PROGRAM SO LOWER RATES OF
RECIDIVISM AFTER COMPLETING THE
PROGRAM FORTY SEVEN RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION PROGRAMS COSTS
JUST THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER PARTICIPANT COMPARED TO
CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS WHICH SPEND
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO INCARCERATE ONE
PERSON FOR ONE YEAR THE PROBLEM
IS WE ARE SLATED TO SPEND
FOURTEEN POINT TWO BILLION
DURING THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
ALONE ON PRISONS THAT'S
A FOUR PERCENT INCREASE OVER
LAST YEAR AND A WHOPPING FIFTY
EIGHT PERCENT INCREASE SINCE
JUST TWENTY TWELVE A MERE DECADE
AGO OUR PRISON SPENDING REMAINS
OUT OF CONTROL AND THERE REMAINS
AN ENORMOUS AND VERY TROUBLING
GAPS BETWEEN WHAT WE SPEND EVERY
ON PRISONS IN THE AMOUNT WE
INVEST IN PREVENTING CRIME AND
HARM FROM OCCURRING IN THE FIRST
PLACE PROP FORTY SEVEN IS
SHOWING US EVERY DAY WHAT WOULD
BE POSSIBLE IF WE ARE INVESTING
IN PROVEN AND EFFECTIVE CRIME
PREVENTION PROGRAMS TO SCALE
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN SIX
TO ROLL BACK PROP FORTY SEVEN
BY CREATING NEW EXCEPTIONS
THAT WILL REINSTATE FELONY
CHARGES FOR A WIDE RANGE OF
OFFENSES THE PROPOSED CHANGES
ARE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE IN
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE EXISTING LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITH THE OPTIONS TO IMPOSE
FELONY CHARGES AND PUNISHMENT
FOR HABITUAL SHOPLIFTERS AND
THOSE COMMITTING MORE SERIOUS
CRIMES EVEN WHERE THE PROPERTY
INVOLVED IS LESS THAN NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS AND FOR
POSSESSING OR USING STOLEN
FIREARMS REGARDLESS OF THE
VALUE OF THE STOLEN FIREARM WITH
THIS BILL AIMS TO DO THE VERY
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE KNOW WORKS
BEST TO INTERRUPT CYCLES OF
CRIME AND VIOLENCE INSTEAD OF
CREATING NEW FUNDING FOR CRIME
PREVENTION THIS BILL WOULD FORCE
US TO SPEND EVEN MORE THAN WE
ALREADY DO ON OUR PRISONS WHAT
YOU WROTE IN THE MONEY SAVED
BY PROP FORTY SEVEN FOR CRIME
PREVENTION THANK YOU YOU
ARE YOU MISTER WHEN
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES MY
APOLOGIES YEAH I MEAN
-- TO ADD WOOD MISTER
LITTLE I STATED --
MOVING THE BAR FROM NINE
FIFTY TO FIVE HUNDRED DOES NOT
ALLEVIATE THE UNDERLYING ISSUES
THAT CAUSE PEOPLE TO SEE THAT
AS IMMEDIATE REMEDY TO THE
ECONOMIC DISPOSITIONS --
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
I'M ESCALATING THE PENALTY
FOR PETTY THEFT AND CASTING A
WIDER NET TO CAPTURE A LARGER
DEMOGRAPHIC -- NOW BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR INCARCERATION
IN A LIFETIME A SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS DID NOT A REMEDY --
TO TO ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
ISSUES AND SO FAR THIS FOR
GHOST THE REASON RIGHT THERE
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL IT INSIDE
I'M PROGRAM THANK YOU ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION NAME AN ORGANIZATION
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND ARE
GRATEFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING BARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
SERIK ME ON BEHALF OF
THE NATION'S JUSTICE AND
RESPECT OPPOSITION THANK YOU
IF SUPPORTERS SENT FROM THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
OF BUT ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SO NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR --
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWO SEVEN ONE EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO IN YOUR
PHONE AND FIRST WE WILL GO TO
LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THAT
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION
AND THAT IS ALL I HAD TO
-- BEFORE WE PROCEED
TO JUST GIVE US A SECOND MISTER
COOPER LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
JONES SAWYER HERE
LACKEY BONTA BRIAN
QUIRK SANTIAGO SEYARTO
WE NOW HAVE A A QUORUM I WILL
QUICKLY READ THROUGH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY BERMAN
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN GIPSON I DON'T
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY THREE GRAYSON I DON'T
NUMBER TEN AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SIX MAIENSCHEIN ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
NINE THIS AREA ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR OH SEVEN
O'DONNELL ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY THREE RIGHT
TO GUESS I DON'T OVER SIXTEEN
AB TWENTY SIX NINETEEN NINETEEN
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE TANG
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETY NINE JONES SAWYER
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY
HI BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN
BRIAN HIGH COURT SANTIAGO
SEYARTO ZERO TWO I
CENTERS DROPPED IT WILL NOT
BRING IT BACK FOR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OR COMMENTS
SEEING AND HEARING NONE --
YOU MAY CLOSE THIS COOPER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M NOT REALLY
SURE WHAT TO SAY MEMBERS ARE TO
FOCUSING UPPER RIVER READ BUT I
DON'T PRISON POPULATION IS DOWN
RIGHT NOW -- SIGNIFICANTLY --
THIS IS FOR CYRIL REPEATED THEFT
SO NOT SURE WHICH DOCUMENTS
YOU'RE RECREATING -- THEFT
IS UP RIGHT NOW PROP FORTY SEVEN
DECRIMINALIZE SERIAL THEFT --
IT'S INTERESTING THERE BEEN SIX
ASSEMBLY BILLS THIS YEAR TO DEAL
WITH THIS AND THEN WHEN SENATE
BILL IT IS A PROBLEM THIS THE
ACA -- I THINK WE CAN ALL SAY
WITH -- OF GOOD CERTAINTY THAT
THIS BILL WITH THE VOTERS THIS
IS A CA TO GO TO THE VOTERS
AND THAT'S REALLY THE ULTIMATE
THING TO ALLOW THE VOTERS TO
DECIDE WHERE THEY WANT TO DEAL
WITH THIS OR NOT THEY WOULD
THEY WOULD VOTE FOR IT -- YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S RAMPANT IT'S AN
ISSUE WE'VE SEEN THE SMASH AND
GRABS AND -- IT'S A WOBBLER
SOLICITOR THIRD CONVICTION SO
-- WE'RE ALL PAYING INCREASED
COSTS FOR THE -- THE CONSUMER
OUT THERE DAY IN AND DAY OUT IT
IS VERY EXPENSIVE -- A LOT OF
FOLKS DON'T WANT TO GO SHOPPING
THERE FOR YOU BEING CAUGHT UP
IN IT SO THIS IS IMPACTING -- IF
IMPACTS BUSINESS OWNERS IMPACT
THE PRICE OF EVERYTHING SO --
IT REALLY IS AN ISSUE AND WHEN
YOU HAVE THIS MANY BILLS IN ONE
SESSION -- WE SEE THAT SO
-- FIFTY S. B. RIVAL THANK
YOU AND INDEED YOUR CONCERN
IS JUSTIFIED WITH THE PLASTER
OF THE PROP FORTY SEVEN BILLS
COMING THROUGH IT'S ALSO SAYS
THAT THE IS ASSEMBLY SITE I
BELIEVE THERE'S QUITE A FEW ON
THE SENATE SIDE THAT ARE THERE
THAT HAVE COME FORTH I BELIEVE
THIS COMMITTEE WE WILL PROBABLY
PASS OUT ABOUT THREE OF THE ONES
THAT CAME OUT AND I WOULD LIKE
FOR THEM TO GIVE IT A CHANCE TO
MAKE PROP FORTY SEVEN BETTER --
AND SO -- YOU KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND --
WHEN HAVE SOME BILLS THAT KIND
OF HOPEFULLY ADDRESS SOME OF
YOUR CONCERNS ARE SECOND DRESS
EVERYTHING BUT THE TEACHER WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE THAT A TRY BUT I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
IN YOUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
-- BUT UNFORTUNATELY THIS --
DOESN'T MEET I THINK WE CAN GET
TO -- ULTIMATELY BUT AGAIN I
I COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING THE
SPORT OF CHAIRS THE COMEDIAN
NOBLE CALL THE ROLL BUT DESERVE
PRO I'M SORRY YOUR MOTION M.
CALL THE ROLL
AND AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER COOPER THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER NO LACKEY LACKEY
HI BONTA BONTA KNOW BRIAN
BRIAN NO CORK SANTIAGO
SEYARTO THEY ARE TO I
DYNAMISM FILLED WITH THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS TO THE
ATTENTION OF THE COMMITTEE
MR MAIENSCHEIN
PRESTEL BECAUSE
SO MY MAIN SHOW YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY NINE ADDS ADDITIONAL
ME MISDEMEANORS TO THE LIST OF
CRIMES THAT PROMPTED A TEN YEAR
BAN FROM OWNING OR POSSESSING
FIREARMS AS WE'VE SEEN
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY
WITH GUN VIOLENCE ALLOWING
FIREARMS IN THE HANDS OF THE
WRONG INDIVIDUALS CAN HAVE
DISASTROUS EFFECTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE PER CAPITA RATE OF
GUN DEATHS IN THE UNITED STATES
WAS THE HIGHEST SINCE THE MID
NINETIES WITH THIRTEEN POINT SIX
GUN DEATHS PER EVERY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE FAR TOO OFTEN
THESE TRAGEDIES ARE PERPETRATED
BY INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SHOWN
PREVIOUS SIGNS OF VIOLENT
BEHAVIOR OR INTENTION TO HARM
UNDER CURRENT LAW INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF OVER FORTY
SPECIFIED MISDEMEANOR VIOLATIONS
ARE PROHIBITED FROM OWNING
OR POSSESSING A FIREARM FOR A
PERIOD OF TEN YEARS AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY NINE ADDS CHILD
ENDANGERMENT AND ELDER ABUSE TO
THE LIST OF CRIMES THAT WARRANTS
A TEN YEAR BAN THIS BILL WILL
HELP GET GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS
OF DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS WITH
ME ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS GEOFF BROOKER THE
SUPERVISING DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY
IN THE SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY'S
GUN VIOLENCE RESPONSE UNIT
K. T. T. OPERATOR WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR FROM MR BROOKER
MISTER BROKER IF YOU GUYS GO
AHEAD THANK YOU THANK
YOU I'M MEHR GLORIA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN YOUR WORK
IN THIS IMPORTANT CHANGE TO
OUR PENAL CODES OUR OFFICE HAS
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL BECAUSE WE SEE HARM DONE
TO CHILDREN AND ELDERS ON A
DAILY BASIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUST EXPLAINED THIS BILL WILL
CLOSE THE SIGNIFICANT LOOPHOLE
CALIFORNIA'S GUN LOCKS ARE LAWS
ALREADY PROHIBIT INDIVIDUALS
FROM HAVING GUNS FOR TEN YEARS
AFTER THEY ARE CONVICTED OF
ASSAULTING A STRANGER BUT
NOT WHEN THEY ABUSE CHILDREN
OR SENIORS IN THESE CRIMES
OFTEN INVOLVE FAMILY MEMBERS
AS PROSECUTORS WINDOW THERE'S
A STRONG CORRELATION BETWEEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SUBSEQUENT
GUN VIOLENCE IF THE ABUSER
POSSESSES A GUT BY REMOVING
THESE GUNS FROM THESE HOUSEHOLDS
WE CAN PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS CHILDREN
IT SENIORS FOR THE ESCALATING
VIOLENCE THAT OCCURS WITH
ABUSERS HAVE UNFETTERED ACCESS
TO GUNS TWENTY TWO THIRTY NINE
WILL ALSO PROTECT CHILDREN IN
ANOTHER WAY BECAUSE IT VIEWS
CHILDREN HAVE AN ELEVATED
TENDENCY TO HARM THEMSELVES IN
THE GATE AND ENGAGE IN SUICIDAL
BEHAVIOR BY READING THEIR
ENVIRONMENT THE FIREARMS WE
REMOVE THE MOST LETHAL MEANS OF
SUICIDE STUDIES SHOW THAT
MINORS WHO ARE PHYSICALLY OR
EMOTIONALLY ABUSED WILL ATTEMPT
SUICIDE AT TWICE THE RATE OF
THEIR PEERS AND FOR CHILDREN
WHO EXPERIENCE SEXUAL ABUSE
THE LIKELIHOOD OF AN ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE INCREASES THREE AND A
HALF TIMES THE CRIMES COVERED
BY TWENTY TO THIRTY NINE -- ALL
MISDEMEANORS NO A LOT OF PEOPLE
THINK THEY HAVE A MISTAKEN
NOTION THAT MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES
ARE NOT SERIOUS BUT THAT'S
SIMPLY NOT TRUE SOME OF THE
CASES THAT WE'VE COME ACROSS AS
A MISDEMEANOR AND CHILD ABUSE
OR ELDER ABUSE CASES INCLUDE
THE FOLLOWING WE HAVE A FATHER
OF TWO TEENAGERS WHO WANT
DRUG THREATEN THEM WITH BROKEN
GLASS THROUGH HIS DAUGHTER TO
THE GROUND AND THEN REPEATEDLY
SLAMMED HER HEAD INTO A DOOR
SHE WAS SENT TO THE HOSPITAL
WITH INJURIES IN ANOTHER CASE
WE HAVE A FATHER WHO TOLD HIS
YOUNG CHILDREN THAT HE WAS GOING
TO SHOOT THEIR MOTHER'S NEW
HUSBAND BUT THAT THEY SHOULDN'T
TELL ANYONE WHICH LEFT BOTH
OF THEM IN THE STATE OF TRAUMA
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME GET
A MIDDLE AGED MAN WHO LIVED
WITH AN ELDERLY MOTHER AND
IS ADDICTED TO DRUGS HE OFTEN
SPOKE OF DEMONS AND SPRINKLE
BOTH OF HIS PARENTS ON PRIOR
OCCASIONS THERE'S ANOTHER
FATHER WHO VERBALLY BE RATED AND
PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED HIS YOUNGER
SON MULTIPLE TIMES CREATING
WITH A PSYCHOLOGIST DESCRIBED
AS EXTREME EMOTIONAL DISTRESS
THESE ARE NOT ENVIRONMENTS THAT
ARE CONDUCIVE TO HOUSEHOLDS
THAT SHOULD HAVE GUNS AND
FINALLY IN A CASE INVOLVING
COMPLETE STRANGERS A MAN HAD
BUDGET A SEVENTY NINE YEAR
OLD ON THE STREET WITHOUT ANY
PROVOCATION AS THE VICTIMS TO
TALKING TO THE EXPRESS THEIR
UNDER OUR SENTENCING LAWS
THESE OFFENDERS COULD BE KEPT
IN CUSTODY FOR NO MORE THAN
ONE YEAR AT TWENTY TWO THIRTY
NINE WOULD PREVENT INDIVIDUALS
LIKE THIS FROM POSSESSING GUNS
WHEN THEY RE ENTER SOCIETY BUT
OUR COMMUNITIES OUR ELDERS AND
OUR CHILDREN WILL BE SAFER FOR
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN FOR SPONSORING
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES K. IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
-- BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY NINE
CA NINE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES
I DON'T SEE ANY WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
K. A. T. AND T. OPERATOR
IF WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE
LINE THOUGH LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
THIS IS THEIR OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
FIRST WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MATURE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
MAX PERRY ON THE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION ALL DONE
SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND THAT IS ALL I HAD IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS I'M OF
A SECOND MHM
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE I ALSO WANT TO MENTION
THAT AND THANK MAYOR TODD GLORIA
AND SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY MARA
ELLIOTT FOR THEIR SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL AS WELL AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION THE
SECOND LET'S CALL FOR THE
QUESTION I'M AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY NINE BY THE MEMORY
MAIENSCHEIN THE MOTION IS
DUE PATH AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER LACKEY LACKEY
I BONTA BONTA HI
BRIAN BRIAN HI QUIRK
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SEYARTO
I WAS IN COLLEGE MEASURES
ARE CALLED IS ONE MORE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MEMBERS THANKS A LOT
YES OKAY
FRIEDMAN YOU ME AND THEM
NUMBER FOUR AB AT TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK
AND TIME WHEN THIS BILL AND
ALSO FOR TERRY JONES SAWYER FOR
BEING A JOINT AUTHORS AB TWENTY
SEVEN FOR FORTY SIX WILL REDUCE
RACIAL AND WEALTH BANK THIS
WITH WEALTH BASED DISPARITIES
ENFORCEMENT OF MINOR TRAFFIC
LAWS WHILE MAINTAINING ROAD
SAFETY BY MAKING THE FOLLOWING
POLICY CHANGES ELIMINATING
LICENSE SUSPENSIONS BASED
SOLELY ON A FAILURE TO APPEAR IN
COURT AND MAKING THE FIRST TWO
OFFENSES OF AN INFRACTION FOR
DRIVING WITHOUT A LICENSE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS -- COME FROM
THE COMMITTEE ON THE REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE ONCE AGAIN THESE
OFFENSES ARE PRIMARILY FINANCIAL
IN NATURE NOT CONNECTED TO
UNSAFE DRIVING OR DO YOU I OR
ANY OF THOSE TYPES OF OFFENSES
THAT WOULD HAVE A COMPELLING
PUBLIC REASON TO NOT HAVE THE
PERSON ON THE ROAD TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON AS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY DIANA BECTON
OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY CONTRA
COSTA AND TYLER NICOLE SMITH
WITH THE LEGAL AID FOUNDATION
OF LOS ANGELES THANK YOU
ON THE FUNDS WE ARE AT
AND T. OPERATOR TO HAVE
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
YES DAN I YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON DINA
BACK IN DISTRICT ATTORNEY
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY ALSO
PRIOR PRESIDING JUDGE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX WHICH WILL REQUIRE DRIVE
WITHOUT OBJECTION OF THE LICENSE
TO BE CHARGED AS AN INFRACTION
FOR THE FIRST TWO VIOLATIONS
AND AND LICENSE SUSPENSIONS
CONSIGLIO CHIP IN COURT AT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY I AM ALWAYS
COMMITTED TO KEEPING OUR STATE
STREET SAFE FROM PEOPLE WHO
ARE DANGEROUS AND SAFEGUARDING
OUR COMMUNITY UNDER THE CURRENT
LAW A PERSON'S LICENSE TO DRIVE
CAN BE SUSPENDED SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY FAILED TO APPEAR IN COURT
THIS IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
INEFFECTIVE A WAY TO GET PEOPLE
TO SHOW UP FOR COURT DATES WHEN
WE TAKE AWAY THEIR ABILITY TO
LEGALLY DRIVE WE MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO WATCH AND
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
THREAT OF LICENSE SUSPENSION
WORK TO GET PEOPLE TO COURT
OR THAT ANYONE EVEN KNOWS
THAT THIS IS A SANCTION THIS
IS CORRECTIVE IT'S JUST NOT
AS EFFECTIVE AND IT ENDANGERS
PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN WE SUSPEND
A LICENSE FOR TECHNICAL REASONS
SUCH AS FAILURE TO APPEAR PEOPLE
MAY CONTINUE TO DRIVE THERE
THEY MAY LOSE THEIR INSURANCE
COVERAGE AS A RESULT OF THE
SUSPENSION AND THAT MAKES
PEOPLE MORE LIKELY TO FLEE THE
SCENE FOLLOWING AN ACCIDENT
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX WILL
MAKE THE FIRST YEAR VIOLATION
FOR DRIVING WITHOUT POSSESSION
OF UNLICENSED AND INFRACTION
RATHER THAN A MISDEMEANOR
ILLEGAL MANY DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
LIKE MYSELF NOW ARE ALREADY
TRIED CHARGING GLIDING WITHOUT
POSSESSION OF UNLICENSED AND
INFRACTION IS THAT THIS YEAR
YOU CAN NOT OFFICIATED WITH
DANGEROUS -- DRIVING OR EVEN
PUBLIC SAFETY MORE BROADLY IT
IS ASSOCIATED WITH PROPERTY I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR TWENTY
PERCENT IMPORTANT THANK YOU
THANK YOU YOU HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
AS CORRECT YES I BELIEVE
ON THE PHONE K. WERE READY
FOR THE ADDITIONAL WITNESS
AT T. OPERATOR GOOD MORNING
PLEASE PLEASE PROCEED GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TYLER NICHOLSON THANK
CURRENTLY MANAGING ATTORNEY
AT THE LEGAL AID FOUNDATION OF
LOS ANGELES ACTUALIZED IN THE
ENTRANCE TO THE CHINESE AND I
WILL SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX -- AS MEASURING FOR
THE LARGEST NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA
WORKING HUNDREDS OF ALL INCOME
CLIENTS MANY OF WHOM ARE BLACK
AND BROWN HIT SHOPPERS OVERCOME
THE COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES AND
TRAUMA THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CURRENT CRIMINAL CONVICTION
AND A LICENSE SUSPENSION
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT FOLKS WHO
ARE A DANGER TO THE COMMUNITY
AT PREVIOUSLY SAID THERE SIMPLY
HARDWORKING FOLKS WHO ARE TRYING
TO DO WHAT THEY CAN TO SURVIVE
SUCH ACTIONS LIKE A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION ARE LIKE BENCHING
CAN KNOCK AN ALREADY UNSTABLE
INDIVIDUAL AND FAMILY FURTHER
OUT OF WHACK AND PUSH THEM
FURTHER AWAY FROM STABILITY
WHERE LICENSES ACTIVE DURING THE
SUSPENSION OF THE LICENSE PLATE
IS EVEN WORKING STRENGTHENED
AN ALREADY STRAPPED PERSON OR
FAMILY AT THAT LICENSE HOLDER
IT OFTEN THE PRIMARY SOURCE
OF TRANSPORTATION WHERE THEY
SELL THEIR FAMILY AND IT MAKES
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO SELL
THEIR OBLIGATIONS LIKE JOBS
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR OWN
WELL BEING ADDITIONALLY IN MOST
CASES INDIVIDUALS ARE UNAWARE
THAT THEY'RE LIKE YOU HAS
BEEN SUSPENDED UNTIL THEY'RE
STOPPED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
-- IN INVERKEITHING WHAT THEY
ARE AWARE OF THE SUSPENSION
DUE TO NON APPEARANCE THEY
ARE UNAWARE OF WHAT MAY HAPPEN
IF THEY APPEAR IN COURT ON IN
OUR FREE THAT THAT EXPERIENCE
MAY WORSEN THEIR SITUATION
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW THE
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES
THAT COME WITH BOTH AND BOTH
MISDEMEANOR CONVICTION AND A
LIFE CHANGING FAN EVEN YEARS
AFTER THE INITIAL INCIDENT AND
WHILE IT HAS BEEN PERPETUATED
THAT A MISDEMEANOR CONVICTION
PLUS HEARING FELONY CONVICTION
WHETHER MISDEMEANOR OR FELONY
IF THEY PERMIT MARC ON THE
RECORD OF AN INDIVIDUAL WHICH
EVEN WHEN EXPANSION NEVER BE
ERASED -- MILLS FIFTEEN EVERY
PUBLIC BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR
HELPING AND MAKING SURE THAT
MAKING YOUR CONVICTIONS WILL
APPEAR IN THE APPLICANT'S
JUDGMENT AND IF YOU ABILITY
OUR QUESTION AND MAKE THEM LESS
VIABLE THAN INDIVIDUALS WITH
NO RECORD AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX WILL BE A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BY REDUCING COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES AND LONG LASTING
HARM THAT ARE CAUSED BY BOTH IN
ITS NEW CONVENTION AND A LICENSE
SUSPENSION -- AND LIFELINES
WILL REMOVE THE UNNECESSARY
PENALTIES FOR FAILURE TO APPEAR
ALLOWING THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILIES -- CANNOT BE
FACED WITH MORE IMPOSSIBLE TRACK
THIS CHRISTIAN BIBLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU OKAY DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE RULING ELECTRICS
PRESSURE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
MARCO TORCH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NATASHA MINSKER ON
BEHALF OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA
PROUD SPONSOR THANK YOU
THERE REGNI ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL JUSTICE AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
IF SUPPORTERS AND FROM THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU OKAY DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES -- IN
OPPOSITION LIKE TO TESTIFY
SAVE NINE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE WELCOME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE IN THE SECOND
IT MOTION SECOND NO COMMENTS
THIS CALL FOR THE QUESTION
SO WHAT BETTER OH YEAH FORGOT
A. T. T. OPERATOR WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALLOW THOSE WHO
MAY BE ONLINE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK EITHER WAY ON AB TWO
SEVEN FOUR SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
THAT IS ONE IN HERE ON YOUR FONG
TAKING BOTH FOR AND AGAINST
YEAH I HAVE
NO AN NGO PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU -- A CALL FOR
THE QUESTION AT THIS POINT
ON AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
THE MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER LACKEY LACKEY NOW
BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN
BRIAN HI CORK QUIRK
I SANTIAGO SEYARTO
SEE OUR TURN NOW FROM QUALITY
THERE'S A COLLEGE TO MARK
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME
GO AHEAD DECEMBER
BONTA YOU MAY GO AHEAD
THE OTHER WORDS
TWENTY ALL
THIS SHOULD BE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY THREE
GOOD MORNING MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HELP WITH THE
AMENDMENTS GUN VIOLENCE IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THAT HAS
PLAGUED OUR COMMUNITIES FOR FAR
TOO LONG IT HAS LED TO THOUSANDS
OF PREMATURE DEATHS AND
INJURIES ANNUALLY AND HAS CAUSED
LIFELONG HEALTH ISSUES INCLUDING
INTERPERSONAL AND GENERATIONAL
TRAUMA WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
MIDST OF THE LARGEST RISE IN
GUN HOMICIDES IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
DISRUPTED MANY ASPECTS OF OUR
LIVES INCLUDING THIS HISTORIC
STRIDES THAT CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
IN PUBLIC SAFETY OVER THE PAST
DECADES MOST CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
EXPERIENCE AN INCREASE IN GUN
HOMICIDES SINCE THE PANDEMIC
VICTIMS HAVE BEEN PREDOMINANTLY
BLACK AND LATINO MALES
KILLED BY GUNS ON OUR STREETS
PARKING LOTS AND VEHICLES
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT GUN VIOLENCE
IS TIGHTLY CONCENTRATED ON A
SMALL NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
AT VERY HIGH RISK OF BEING
EITHER VICTIMS OR PERPETRATORS
OF GUN VIOLENCE THEREFORE
SHOOTINGS ARE OFTEN PREDICTABLE
AND PREVENTABLE IF EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
EFFORTS ARE IN PLACE FOR THESE
HIGH RISK INDIVIDUALS AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY THREE WOULD DO JUST
THAT BY ESTABLISHING THE OFFICE
OF GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION TO
CREATE A PUBLIC HEALTH BASED
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION STRATEGY
IN COLLABORATION WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS IN ADDITION TO
CREATING A STRATEGY THIS BILL
WILL ALLOCATE DEDICATED STAFF
TO THE OFFICE OF GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION TO HELP IMPLEMENT THE
STRATEGY WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO ENSURE THAT
THESE EFFORTS TO NOT JUST END
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS WITH ME
IS WHAT IS TODAY IS GIVE MY
SISTER AT THIS THE CHIEF OF
OFFICE OF PREVENTION OF VIOLENCE
PREVENTION IN THE CITY OF
OAKLAND EXACTLY
FIRE BOB
HERTZBERG D.
K. A. T. T. OPERATOR WE
CANNOT HEAR THE WITNESS
WE CAN HEAR GARBLED
WE CAN ACTUALLY ACT ARTICULATE
WHAT WHAT'S BEEN SAID
AT THANK
I'M SORRY CAN YOU CAN THE
SPEAKER PLEASE TRY IT
I DON'T KNOW IF USING A
SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE TRY
PICKING UP THE HANDSET THAT
WAS ACTUAL WITNESS OR JUST
SOME KIND OF INTERFERENCE
AND THE WITNESS'S NAME
PLEASE ESMO SUSPEND THIS
GET A MOTIONS BETTIS
THE END OF ALL YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO SPEAK OVER THE PHONE
LINE CAN I PLEASE HAVE USED
-- SO WE CAN CHECK YOUR VOLUME
EARMARKED
WE GOT SOME PROBLEM HERE LINE
IS OPEN BUT I AM GETTING NO
RICHARD GERE AMMONIA I AM ONLY
I AM ON THE LINE I AM HONORED
IN THE YOU NEED TO GIVE YOUR
PRESENTATION YES
THANK YOU PLEASE TRY
YEAH I DON'T BAKER CHECKING
I AM NOT USING A SPEAKER PHONE
WE CAN
YEAH WE CAN HEAR CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW PLEASE YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES OKAY
MY YES
WE HAVE SOME INTERFERENCE
FOR SOME STRANGE REASON IT'S
ALMOST LIKE A FEEDBACK THAT
WE'RE HEARING IT'S AN ECHO
WELL YES I AM HERE MY NAME
IS DIEM ASSESSMENT IS I AM
CURRENTLY TO KEEP A PILOT'S
PREVENTION -- EMPLOYMENT
FOR THE CITY OF OAKLAND
FORMALLY THE DEPUTY MAYOR JOHN
YEAH
OKAY AT THAT YOUR
PRESENTATION HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
THANK YOU STE
YOU'RE COMPETING
WITH THE FEEDBACK
VERY DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND
OKAY WHAT ABOUT NOW YEAH
WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE TRY
GO AHEAD OKAY GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KI¿M ASSESSMENT I AM
CURRENTLY THE CHIEF OR VIOLENCE
PREVENTION TO THE CITY OF
OAKLAND FORMALLY THE DEPUTY
MAYOR BEGAN REDUCTION IN YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE CITY OF LA
I AM I AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGY
PROPOSED BY AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY THREE I SEE HAS BEEN
AFFECTED BEEN FOCUSING ON ACTIVE
LEVELS OF VIOLENCE AS WELL
AS ADDRESSING THE UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS THAT GENERATE
VIOLENCE -- IN OAKLAND --
IN MOST SUNDAYS AND -- YOU
KNOW DON'T HAVE CENTRAL AMERICA
-- THE MODEL IS CURRENTLY BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN THE GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATIONS OF OAKLAND THEY TOOK
VIOLENCE CULTURE TWENTY
FOUR PERCENT OF SEX OFFENSES
IT IS ALSO A MODEL THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN A LANE TWO
THOUSAND NINE HOW IT WILL REDUCE
THE NINE CATEGORIES OF PART ONE
CRIME -- THROUGHOUT THE CITY
-- THIS MODEL LOOKS OF VIOLENCE
IS A COMMUNICABLE DISEASE THAT
CAN BE ADDRESSED BY FOCUSING
ON SPECIFIC LOCATION SPECIFIC
PEOPLE SPECIFIC TIMES OF THE DAY
AND DAYS OF THE WEEK THE SOLVE
VIOLENCE RATHER THAN DISPLACE IT
-- AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
THREE PROPOSES TO ESTABLISH
A STATEWIDE OFFICE THAT
WOULD HELP ON A POLICY LEVEL
TO INFORM PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPLEMENTATION IN MULTIPLE
CITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THEREFORE I A -- WELCOME
-- THIS BILL I'D WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK CLOSELY ON
IN ON THE SCENE IMPLEMENTATION
TAKE PLACE STATEWIDE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU AND NOW WILL BRING IT TO THE
ROOM FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
YES BARCO
GEORGE ON THE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
HI AUNTIE SANDRA WHAT STONE
FROM FOLSOM A VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT THEY GIVE
ALEX NAVARRO MOMS DEMAND ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
RUDY HAS BEEN OF THE MURRAY
VOLUNTEERED MOMS DEMAND ACTION
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
I WILL LISTEN TO EVERYTHING
ANY WITNESSES AND -- GO
TO PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT
AT T. OPERATORS COULD YOU OPEN
UP FOR AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
THREE BONTA WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY THREE IN SPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME AND FIRST WE WILL GO WITH
LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN NEXT WE'LL GO WITH LINE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE MORNING CARE AND MEMBERS OF
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY ON BEHALF
OF EVERY TOWN FOR GUN SAFETY
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXRAD LINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE LINE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE MORNING JR MEMBERS THEN
THE QUESTION ABOUT -- WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
KEENER ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WERE IN SUPPORT
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- HI MY NAME IS KAREN
GANADO I AM A VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE FROM WEST SACRAMENTO
AND THEN AND CHUNKS OF WORK
AND THAT IS EVERYONE I HAD IN
Q. THANK YOU NOW WILL LISTEN
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ARE ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION
WITHIN THE HEARING ROOM
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AT&T OPERATOR
COULD YOU OPEN UP THE LINE
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
THAT IS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
OF THE BILL AND I HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. THANK
YOU WILL NOW BRING A
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THE CORK
ON REFORM WHAT
-- ARE YOU WE WERE ABLE
TO GET THIS INTO THE BUDGET
WE ARE WORKING ON THAT IT
HAS BEEN THE INTENTION ALL
ALONG TO BE LET ME KNOW IF
I CAN HELP THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU HAVE SOME SAY MISTER LUCKY
YEAH I JUST A COMMENT THAT --
WHAT'S NOTABLY ABSENT FROM
THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS THE
FAIR TO ADDRESS THE ACTIONS
THE PERPETRATORS WHO COMMIT
CRIME WITH A GUN AND SO I
WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU MISTER SEA OTTER YES
FOR ME THIS IS EASIER TO SUPPORT
AS A METHOD OF ADDRESSING
VIOLENCE -- BECAUSE
THERE'S THE GUN VIOLENCE THERE
IS THE ARE THE VIOLENCE USING
A GUN THERE'S A VIOLENCE USING
A KNIFE IS A VIOLENT USING
MACHETES THERE'S VIOLENCE USING
JUST A CORD -- TO STRANGLE
PEOPLE -- I'VE I'VE SEEN
IT ALL AND THERE IS
A EPIDEMIC OF VIOLENCE OUT THERE
BUT IT'S NOT JUST GUN VIOLENCE
VIOLENCE IN GENERAL AND --
IN IT I I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING IS FOR A A A
TAX OF OF ADDRESSING
THE UNDERLYING NEEDS BUT THOSE
UNDERLYING NEEDS APPLY TO ALL
OF THOSE THINGS NOT JUST GUN
VIOLENCE AND THIS MAKES IT SOUND
LIKE IT'S JUST GUN VIOLENCE
IT'S HAVING WE'RE HAVING ISSUES
WITH IT'S NOT IT'S VIOLENCE
IN GENERAL AND WHATEVER THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES OF THOSE
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND --
AND AND SO IT IT MAKES ME A
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO JUST SAY
HEY LET'S LET'S JUST ADDRESS
GUN VIOLENCE BECAUSE ALL OF IT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
THEN YOU MAY CLOSE RESPOND TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY THREE WILL HELP
FACILITATE A PROCESS BY WHICH
AT THROUGH COLLABORATION WITH
ALL OF OUR RELEVANT STATE
AGENCIES COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A FULL THROTTLED
ROBUST HEALTH BASED APPROACH
TO GUN VIOLENCE WHICH IS
IN OF ITSELF SOMETHING
THAT HAS PLAGUED OUR CITIES
AND OUR STATE A SPECIFICALLY
GUN VIOLENCE AND WITH THAT I
ON BEHALF OF MY PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU A CHURCH
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE CALL
THE ROLL ON AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MIA
BONTA THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY NEL
BONTA I BONTA HI
BRIAN BRIAN I WORK
I WORK AT A SAN DIEGO
SEYARTO THERE TO NOW
IT MEASURES ON CALL NEED
ONE MORE VOTE THANK YOU
I SEE WE HAVE MR LOW
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER OFFERS SO
MR LOW YOU MAY PRESENT
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
FIFTY FIVE LOW -- CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES CURES DATABASE
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- IT'S
DELIGHTFUL TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S AN AYE RECOMMENDATIONS
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR THIS TIME
WITH RESPECT TO OUR BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
WHICH HELPS TO ADDRESS SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AS A HEALTH ISSUE VERSUS
A CRIMINAL JUSTICE ISSUE A
WITH ME TODAY IS A BRAND MARGIE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT YES WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BRANDON
MARCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AS THE VERY
COMPREHENSIVE HISTORY PROVIDED
IN THE HOUSE IT SHOWS THE IDEA
OF THE COLLECTION OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE PRESCRIBING HISTORY
IN CALIFORNIA STARTED BACK IN
THE NINETEEN THIRTIES WITH A
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOCUS OVER TIME
THE LEGISLATURE HAS GRADUALLY
EXPANDED WHAT IS NOW KNOWN AS
CURES INTO THE USE IN CLINICAL
SETTINGS WHEN THE REQUIREMENT
TO CHECK THE KERRS DATABASE
PRIOR TO PRESCRIBING A SCHEDULE
TO THREE OR FOUR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE BECAME MANDATORY THE
LEGISLATURE DICTATED THAT CURES
BE A MANDATORY PART OF CLINICAL
PRACTICE WHILE THERE IS STILL
ON FORTUNATE COMPONENT TO CARE
AS MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS ARE
REQUIRED TO USE IT FOR PURPOSES
OF THEIR WORK IT IS INCUMBENT
WITH THAT CLINICAL EMPHASIS THAT
CURES BE ADMINISTERED WITH THE
REQUIRED FUNCTION SERVING AS A
TOOL TO ASSIST IN THE CARE OF
PATIENTS IN MIND THE GOAL OF
AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE IST HAVE
CURES PLACE IN AN AGENCY OR
BOARD THAT IS FOCUSED ON HEALTH
HAS EXPERIENCING HAVE EXPERIENCE
MANAGING LARGE HEALTHCARE
DATABASES AND HAS RELATIONSHIPS
WITH HEALTHCARE STAKEHOLDERS
TO THAT THE DATABASE'S ABILITY
TO SUPPORT THE DELIVERY OF
CARE AND RESEARCH ARE CENTERED
IN ITS ADMINISTRATION THIS
WILL THIS BILL WOULD FURTHER
THE GOALS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ESTABLISHED WORK HERE'S AN
A LINE CALIFORNIA WITH OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE TRANSITIONED
AWAY FROM A LAW ENFORCEMENT
MODEL I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
TWENTY FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND SUPPORT
-- ANY WITNESSES
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM
SEEING NONE -- WILL GO
TO THE AT&T OPERATORS FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE LOW
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME
AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU CHAIR RIGHT SPENT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRETTY AFTER METAL SO MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
AND NO
ONE ELSE CAN KILL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL NOW HEAR
FROM WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
SEEING NONE CONSUMING THERE'S
NOT OUTSIDE THE ROOM EITHER SO
WE'LL GO TO THE AT&T OPERATORS
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE LOW
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AT THE TIME
AT ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE
AND I HAVE NO IN INDIA THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- THE BILL SECOND
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT
THAT AND THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS I I THINK
WE'VE WE'VE ALL BEEN TRYING
TO WORK ON CURES FOR QUITE
AWHILE I THINK YOU FINALLY
GET THE SWEET SPOT WHERE
WHERE WE CAN FINALLY MOVE
FORWARD BECAUSE IT JUST HAS NOT
BEEN TAKEN CARE OF ADEQUATELY
TO ARTS AT LEAST TO THE ASSEMBLY
SATISFACTIONS RIGHT I THINK YOU
HAVE THE RIGHT APPROACH THIS
IS CHAIRS RECOMMENDING AND I
HELLO AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
BY SEVEN MEMBER LOW THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER II
LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN HI
CORK CORK I SAN DIEGO
SEYARTO SEE OUR TOP
HI THE MEASURE PASSES
-- -- I'D I KNOW
MISTER BRYANT THIS IS ACROSS
THE HALL CHAIRING A COMMITTEE
-- MISS FRIEDMAN
WE'RE GONNA GO OKAY
WHO ELSE IS PREVENTIVE WAS
SAYS WHEN I WAS GROWING
MR MAIENSCHEIN
-- WHAT ABOUT MR GREY OR MISTER
HOLD THANK YOU
THEY WILL ASK THE OFFICE
NOBODY'S HOME YEAH
NOT AVAILABLE OKAY
LOOK WHO COULD WELL
THE REQUESTED HE'S
A KILLER WEBER --
SAID ULTIMATELY
AND OUR FAVORITE
MEMBER MR SANTIAGO
YEAH EXISTENCE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE
RIGHT TO TO --
THAT IS CALLED OKAY OKAY
WHAT IT IS TO
READ WE NEED TO DO
SEVENTY THE END OF
AND NO ONE'S EVER LATE
MISTER CHAIR CAN
WE ADD ON TO THE
ROLE SURE LET'S DO THAT
IT SUGGESTED MR CORK
WOULD YOU ADD ONS NOW
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK
I AM THE CONSECUTIVE
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER
PARK CORK NOW
FOR
WE
THE --
I THINK I MISSED THE BOAT
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX
BY SUMMER FRIEDMAN THIS
MEASURE IS ON CALL JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI
THAT MEASURE REMAINS ON CALL
REPORTER MAIENSCHEIN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO
THIRTY NINE BY SEVEN MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN THIS MEASURE I
WAS ON CALL JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER HI THAT MEASURE NOT
PASSED -- I APOLOGIZE
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
NINE CORK HIGH COURT I
IN ORDER YEAH
--
UHHUH TO WORK
SURE SURE
THIS ACROSS THE WHOLE -- JOBS
IN THE VERIFICATION PROCESS YEAH
IT KIND OF IT JUST THE FACT
FINANCING
YOUR FINGERS CROSSED BY PEOPLE
MORE IMPORTANT SHOWS THAT
TEXTILES JUSTIN IS
YEAH
-- YEAH
YEAH THE
BILL GAME
REALLY -- THERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER IS CLOSE
YOU CAN COME IN AND PRESENT ALSO
REALLY YEAH
YEAH
MMHM
SO FORTUNATE
YEAH
I'M GOING SIX --
RUBIO WELL YOU'RE NOT
--
SORT OF
AND NOW MOST OF
OKAY
RIGHT YEAH
FOR THE MONEY
RIGHT I DON'T KNOW THE SIX
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY RIGHT
--
WELL GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
THIS BILL ADDRESSES SKYROCKETING
RATES OF CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFT BY REQUIRING CAR DEALERS
TO PERMANENTLY MARK CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS WITH THE VIN OF
THE VEHICLE TO WHICH THEY ARE
ATTACHED CRIMINALIZING THE
TAMPERING OF REMOVAL OF THAT
BEEN MARKING AND REQUIRING
SMOG CHECKS TO INCLUDE A
NOTIFICATION TO DRIVERS
ABOUT WHETHER THEIR CATALYTIC
CONVERTER HAS BEEN MARKED
THESE PARTS WORK -- COMPONENT
VEHICLES EXHAUST SYSTEM THAT
REDUCES OUR HARMFUL
AIR EMISSIONS BY CONVERTING
HYDROCARBONS AND CARBON
MONOXIDE INTO LAW WATER
VAPOR AND CARBON DIOXIDE IN
ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THIS THEY
CONTAIN PRECIOUS METALS LIKE
PALLADIUM RHODIUM AND PLATINUM
WALL THEFT IS NOTHING NEW
RECENT SPIKES IN THE VALUE OF
PRECIOUS METALS TRACK A SPIKE
IN THEFTS FOR EXAMPLE FIVE
YEARS AGO RHODIUM COST EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS BUT
NOW SELLS FOR MORE THAN EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
OVER THAT SAME PERIOD THEFTS
HAVE INCREASED MORE THAN TENFOLD
IN CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION
ACCOUNTING FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
PERCENT OF ALL CLAIMS FILED
WITH STATE FARM FOR EXAMPLE
HIGH PRICES FOR THE PRECIOUS
METALS FOUND IN THESE CONVERTERS
ARE EXPECTED TO CONTINUE DUE
TO SUPPLY DISRUPTIONS CAUSED BY
THE RUSSIAN INVASION OF UKRAINE
WITH RUSSIA PRODUCING ALMOST
FORTY PERCENT OF THE WORLD'S
MIND PALLADIUM SO LONG
AS THIS FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
EXISTS WE SHOULD EXPECT TO
SEE THESE THEFTS CONTINUE
WHILE VEHICLES MOST OFTEN
HIT BY THIEVES INCLUDING SUVS
AND FLEET VEHICLES WITH HIGH
GROUND CLEARANCE AS WELL AS THE
TOYOTA PRIUS ANY VEHICLE CAN
BE TARGETED ONE STOLEN THIEVES
TYPICALLY FLIP THESE PARTS FOR
FIFTY TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
WHILE VICTIMS CAN EXPECT TO PAY
ANYWHERE FROM ONE THOUSAND TO
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET THE
VEHICLE FIXED UNLESS
THE THIEF IS CAUGHT IN THE ACT
RED HANDED LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
FEW TOOLS TO INVESTIGATE THIS
CRIME IT IS DIFFICULT TO LINK
AN INDIVIDUAL WITH ANY SPECIFIC
STOLEN CATALYTIC CONVERTER
RIGHT NOW LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
PULL OVER A SUSPECT WITH DOZENS
OF STOLEN CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
SITTING IN THEIR TRUNK AND
HAVE NO MECHANISM TO HOLD THAT
INDIVIDUAL ACCOUNTABLE AS A
RESULT EVEN WHEN A SUSPECT
IS ARRESTED MANY ARE NEVER
PROSECUTED CONSISTENT WITH BEST
PRACTICES RECOMMENDED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY AS WELL AS THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
REQUIRES THE PERMANENT MARKING
OF KHALKHIN BURGER WITH THE
VEHICLES THAT UNDER THIS BILL
DOES HAVE SCALLOP CONVERTER
CAN BE EASILY TRACED BACK TO
ITS ORIGINAL VEHICLE AND LEGAL
OWNERSHIP CAN BE ESTABLISHED
IF THE MARKING ON THE PART
IS REMOVED THE POSSESSION OF
THAT PART IS A CRIME WHICH
WILL SERVE AS A SIGNIFICANT
DETERRENT FOR ANY BLACK MARKET
REPAIR SHOP OR METAL RECYCLER
-- TO TAKE POSSESSION OF THE
STORM PART I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT -- THIS BILL REMAINS A WORK
IN PROGRESS -- THERE ARE SOME
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT ENSURING THE MARKING
REQUIREMENT IS SUFFICIENTLY
FLEXIBLE AND SUFFICIENTLY NARROW
FOR EXAMPLE THE CAR DEALERS ARE
PROVIDE COMPELLING INFORMATION
THAT HIGHLIGHTS VARIOUS
EXHAUSTED SIGNS SOME OF WHICH
VERY THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER
DEEP INSIDE THE VEHICLE
REQUIRING DEALERS TO MAKE A
CALLACHAN BIRD WITH THIS DESIGN
IS IMPRACTICAL AS THEY WOULD
HAVE TO DISASSEMBLE MAJOR
ENGINE COMPONENTS IN ORDER TO
ACCESS THE PART FORTUNATELY
THE SAME DESIGN ALSO MAKES
ACCESSING THAT COVER DIFFICULT
FOR THIEVES -- AND THOSE
VEHICLES ARE USUALLY NOT
TARGETED I'M COMMITTED TO TAKING
FUTURE AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS
THESE PRACTICAL CONCERNS AND I
APPRECIATE TO PRODUCTIE STATIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH THE OPPOSITION SO
FAR -- TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE JONATHON FELDMAN
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION TRAVIS AUSTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR
FOR A WE COULD HAVE THEM
APPROACHING LOW OKAY
THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY SO THEY'RE
NOT HERE I HAVE FALSE ALARMS
SO EASY OPERATION YOU HAVE HAS
OFTEN EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
DO YOU HAVE TRAVIS AUSTIN
ON THE TELEPHONE TESTIFIED
COVERING DISTRIBUTOR AND I'M
I'M HERE -- YOU MAY BEGIN
WHILE WE WAIT FOR JONATHAN TO
ATTEND THANK YOU THANK YOU
-- GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
TRAVIS AUSTIN AND THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY TWO DUE TO THE
NATURE OF THE CRIME CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THEFT POSES UNIQUE
CHALLENGES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PROSECUTORS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THOSE CHALLENGES HEAD
ON CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFT IS
DIFFICULT TO ENFORCE BECAUSE THE
CRIME ITSELF CAN BE COMPLETED IN
MINUTES AND THE STOLEN CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS ARE TYPICALLY DEVOID
OF ANY IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
THIS MEANS THAT UNLESS THE
PERPETRATORS CAUGHT IN THE
ACT IT IS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO IDENTIFY STOLEN CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THE STOLEN CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS ARE THEN TYPICALLY
SOLD TO AUTO DISMANTLING OR
SCRAP METAL YARDS OR CORPS
RECYCLERS OR THEY ARE OFTEN
MIXED IN WITH LEGITIMATELY
OBTAIN CATALYTIC CONVERTERS AT
THESE BUSINESSES EVEN IF CURRENT
RECORD KEEPING REQUIREMENTS ARE
COMPLIED WITH IT IT'S SIMPLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO DISCERN WHAT
PART OF THEIR INVENTORY IS
COMPRISED OF STOLEN PROPERTY
NOW IN ORDER TO INVESTIGATE AND
PROSECUTE ANY RECEIPT OF STOLEN
PROPERTY CASE THE THRESHOLD
DETERMINATION IS WHETHER OR NOT
THE PROPERTY IS ACTUALLY STOLEN
WITHOUT IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
ON THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER ONE
FOR SENATE SIMPLY IS UNABLE TO
MAKE THIS DETERMINATION THIS
BILL SOLVES THAT PROBLEM BY
ENSURING THAT ALL NEW OR USED
VEHICLES ARE EQUIPPED WITH
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS THAT ARE
PERMANENTLY MARKED WITH THE
VIN NUMBER THIS BILL GIVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE ABILITY TO CROSS
REFERENCE CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
THEY ARE INVESTIGATING WITH
KNOWN STEP STOLEN CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
DETERMINE HOW MANY CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS IN THE BUSINESSES
INVENTORY ARE REPORTED STOLEN
AND CREATED CHAIN OF CUSTODY
THAT LEADS BACK TO THE VICTIM OF
THE FAST IDENTIFYING THE VICTIM
IS CRITICAL AND ANY SUBSEQUENT
PROSECUTION IN CONCLUSION THIS
BILL WILL NOT ONLY ASSIST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PROSECUTORS
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT WILL
PROVIDE JUSTICE TO MORE VICTIMS
IN THE TURF CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFT IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU --
MR FELDMAN IN THE ROOM
BUT SEEING HIM THERE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF --
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO GREAT
SPEAKING SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BILL THE
ETHYLENE SHANTI PATH OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE THANK YOU
AGAIN THAT WAS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AND
NEXT WE HAVE LINE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING CHURCH REMEMBERS
WHEN YOU MENTION A LARGE AND
I REPRESENT JAMES BRADLEY
RUNNING FOR YOUR TENANT AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
AB TWO SIX EIGHT TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU WILL GO TO THE ROOM AND
THEN THERE'S SOMEONE IN ROME
IN SUPPORT OR ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM GETS IN SUPPORT
GOOD MORNING CHEN MURMURS
MEMBERS EXCUSE ME ERICA
ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
VALLEY CLEAN AIR NOW IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NOT ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
-- ON THE RECORD I HAVE IT
TATUM ADLER TESTIFY IN PERSON
CONTRACT IF
IF YOU JONATHAN FRIEDMAN
HERE NOW IF YOU IF YOU DON'T
MIND MISS ADLER IF WE COULD
LET HIM FINISH IT AND THEN
WILL GO STRAIGHT TO YOU
I MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
APOLOGIES FOR BEING LATE --
LOTTA CONSTRUCTION OUTSIDE --
JONATHON FELDMAN OUR STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION -- APPRECIATE
THE TIME THERE'S NO PANACEA
TO SOLVE AN EXTRAORDINARY
INCREASE IN CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFT THEY WERE EXPERIENCING
ACROSS THE STATE THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT CHANGES
NEEDED TO HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT
-- CUT DOWN ON THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS OCCURRING IN
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
REPRESENTS AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE POLICY SOLUTION BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER CATALYTIC
CONVERTER CONVERTERS WITH
THE VEHICLE IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER ENGRAVED ON THE PART
AND MAKING IT A VIOLATIONS
KNOWINGLY POSSESS A CATALYTIC
CONVERTER WITH THE VIN
NUMBER REMOVED OR ALTERED
LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL HAVE
EVIDENCE NEEDED TO PROVE
A CRIME WAS COMMITTED THIS
ADDRESSES ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS LAW ENFORCEMENT FACES
ON THE ISSUE WHICH IS THAT
EVEN WHEN INDIVIDUALS FOUND
IN POSSESSION OF MULTIPLE
DETACH CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
IT IS DIFFICULT TO PROVE THAT
A CRIME HAS BEEN COMMITTED
WITHOUT EVIDENCE THE PARTS WERE
STOLEN TO ADDRESS THIS LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ACTUALLY
IN MULTIPLE CITIES PARTNERED
WITH AUTO REPAIR DEALERS
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION TO
OFFER OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
PUBLIC TO GET THEIR CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS AND GRAPE AND IT
HAS BEEN HELPFUL IN IDENTIFYING
STOLEN PARTS AND SOLVING CASES
BY MAKING IT A STATEWIDE
REQUIREMENT THAT MORE AND MORE
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS BEING
GRAPE LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL
BE GIVEN THE ADVANTAGE TO
FIGHT AGAINST THEM TARGETED
-- THE RAMPANT THEFT AGAIN
THERE IS NO UNIVERSAL CURE
BUT THERE ARE CRITICAL STEPS
THAT WE CAN TAKE TO MAKE AN
IMPACT IN AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO TAKES A HUGE STRIDE FOR
THAT REASON WE ASK FOR EITHER
THANK YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHO MAY
BEGIN GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TATUM ACKER
WAS SAMPSON VISORS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION I SEE
IN CDA HAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY TWO AND APPRECIATES
THE AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO
CONTINUE A DIALOGUE WITH US
ON THIS BILL -- AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS THIS
MORNING AS WELL I'M THIRSTY
IN CDA SUPPORTS THE UNDERLYING
INTENT OF THE BILL AND TO THIS
END CURRENTLY SUPPORTS OTHER
CATALYTIC CONVERTER BILLS THAT
ARE FOCUSED ON ENFORCEMENT
AS IT RELATES TO THIS BILL
SEE INSIDIOUS CONCERNS RELATE
SPECIFICALLY TO THE REQUIREMENT
THAT DEALERSHIPS PERMANENTLY
MARK OR EDGE THE VIN NUMBER
INTO THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER
BEFORE THE VEHICLE CAN BE SOLD
MANY VEHICLE MODELS INCORPORATE
THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER IS
PART OF THE EXHAUST MANIFOLD
REQUIRING DEALERSHIP TECHNICIANS
TO DISASSEMBLE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE VEHICLE ENGINE
JUST TO ACCESS THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER I AM JUST BY WAY OF
TWO EXAMPLES TO PERMANENTLY
MARK ONE FOOTBALL THE MODEL
IT WOULD TAKE A DEALERSHIP
TECHNICIANS TWO POINT EIGHT
TO FOUR HOURS TO PERMANENTLY
MARK ONE VEHICLE DEPENDING ON
THE ENGINE VARIANTS AND FOR
CERTAIN ACURA MODELS AND IT CAN
TAKE ANYWHERE FROM TWO TO FIVE
HOURS SO I AM C. AND C. A. AS
I MENTIONED REALLY APPRECIATES
THE AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH US ON A MORE TARGETED
IN STREAMLINED SOLUTION WHILE
ALSO ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
NEW CAR DEALERSHIPS ARE NOT
SADDLED WITH THE LABOR INTENSIVE
AND COSTLY OBLIGATION OF
PERMANENTLY MARKING EVERY SINGLE
VEHICLE THEY SELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN ROME
THE MOBILE TO THE PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF H.
B. TWO SIX EIGHT TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONCE AGAIN IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE THIRTEEN
YES HI THIS IS CURT AUGUSTINE
HOW WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION -- WE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THE BILL
BUT OUR -- I WANT TO COMMEND
MR GRAY ON THE COMMENTS HE
MADE TODAY MANY OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE WERE ECHOED BY
THE NEW CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE HOPE TO WORK ON THE
ETCHING PROVISION OF THE
BILL WITH MR GREY THANK YOU
THANK YOU NOW LINE FORTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
OLYMPIA CAMPBELL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO THIS
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
NOTHING ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU WITHOUT BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
BUT THE COURT
ONE OF THE OPPOSE IT
ONE OF THOSE IN THE POST SAID
THAT -- IF YOU'RE NOT CAREFUL
YOU CAN DAMAGE THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER WHEN YOU ADD TO IT
HI HAVE YOU LOOKED INTO THAT
WE HAVE --
YEAH I ACTUALLY CAN'T SPEAK TO
YOU KNOW EVERY MODEL VEHICLE BUT
FRANK THIS IS A SERVICE THAT IS
CURRENTLY OFFERED SO IF YOU TOOK
YOUR VEHICLE DOWN YOU CAN GET
YOUR CALENDAR AT STE AT TODAY
-- THAT CLEARLY DEMONSTRATES
THAT IT'S -- MULTIPLE THERE
MAY BE NUANCE IS STRICTLY
BECAUSE MANY OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
OUTSIDE OF DISPATCHING -- TO
ENSURE THAT THAT -- YOU KNOW
VIN NUMBER IS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CATHOLIC CONVERT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE MOVE THE BILL
ITS RESPONSE TO SEE AFTER HAD A
QUESTION FIRST AND THEN RESPECT
-- A QUESTION REGARDING THE
EASE OF ACCESS THAT THAT
WITNESS WAS TALKING ABOUT --
IS THERE ARE POTENTIAL FOR
-- EXEMPTIONS TO BE MADE FOR
THOSE TYPE OF VEHICLES BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK EIGHT EIGHT I I
THINK THE WHOLE OPERATION OF
STEALING CATALYTIC CONVERTER
AND THEY USUALLY GET HIM OFF OF
TRUCKS BECAUSE THEY'RE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE YOU CAN GET IN LIKE
THREE OR FOUR MINUTES WITH A
BLOW TORCH BUT I DON'T THINK
YOU CAN DO THAT WITH A VOLVO OR
WHERE AN ACURA AND -- SEWERS
ARE YOU LOOKING INTO MAKING
MAKING SOME EXEMPTIONS FOR --
THE VEHICLES THAT DON'T HAVE
EASE AND THAT ARE NOT EASILY
ACCESSED BECAUSE THE OTHER ONE
TO BE EASY BUT DOES I COULD I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE WOULD
MAKE THEM DO THAT WELL I THINK
IT'S A FAIR POINT OF CONCERN
OBVIOUSLY OFFER THAT UP IN
MY INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS --
WE'RE ACTUALLY OPEN AND THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ARE CURRENTLY
ONGOING BETWEEN MY OFFICE
AND THE VARIOUS ASSOCIATIONS
REPRESENT NEW CAR DEALERS AND
MANUFACTURERS CETERA -- WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A PRACTICAL A PATH
FORWARD HERE -- SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WE HAVE REQUIRED
FEDERALLY EIGHTEEN PARTS
INCLUDING THE TRANSMISSION THE
ENGINE TO BE MARKED WITH A BAT
RIGHT THAT'S PART OF THE FEDERAL
MOTOR VEHICLE THEFT PREVENTION
STANDARD THAT HAS BEEN IN PLACE
SINCE NINETEEN FORCE THIS IS A
TIME TESTED PRACTICE --
THAT'S EFFECTIVE BUT -- WE
OBVIOUSLY CONSIDER ALL OF
THOSE FACTORS AND WE DON'T
WANT TO BE COUNTER PRODUCTIVE
IN THE SENSE OF REQUIRING A --
ENGINE TO BE TAKEN COMPLETELY
APART IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THIS SERVICE BUT SAME TIME WE
WANT TO CAPTURE THE LARGEST
NUMBER VEHICLES NIGHT I ALMOST
DON'T GO A DAY IN MY OFFICE
WITHOUT GETTING COMMUNICATION
FROM CONSTITUENTS THAT THIS IS
HAPPEN TO THEM RIGHT AND AND
WHILE WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
CONSIDER THE COST OF ETCHING
OR -- PROVIDING THAT BEEN ON
A CALCULATOR WE SHOULD ALSO
CONSIDER THE ONE THOUSAND TO
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLAR COST OF
THOSE CONSUMERS RIGHT THAT
THEY HAVE NO RECOURSE -- IN
ADDRESSING EITHER RIGHT RIGHT
SO NO I'M NOT AGAINST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT IS A HUGE
PROBLEM BUT THERE'S OTHER SERIAL
NUMBER YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
-- ARE THAT VIN NUMBERS THAT ARE
STAMPED ON ENGINES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT ARE THOSE AFTERMARKET
THOSE DURING THE MANUFACTURING
OR THE MANUFACTURER YEAH BECAUSE
THAT MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING
ELSE THAT THEY CAN LOOK INTO IT
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMEWHERE
ALL OF THE ABOVE IS ON THE
TABLE AND I HAVE A RECORD
OF BEING A PRETTY PRACTICAL
OR LEGISLATOR AND I WILL
CONTINUE -- -- TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION THANK YOU
YES APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY A CATALYTIC CONVERTER
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE IN MY
DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR -- ENDS
THAT MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIKE REALLY REALLY SUFFERING
FROM THIS ARE THAT AUTO BODY
REPAIR SHOPS WHO HAVE SHARED
WITH ME THAT THEIR BUSINESSES
ARE ON THE VERGE OF GOING
UNDER BECAUSE OF THIS OF THIS
CONCERN I AM A LITTLE A BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
HAVING AT THIS BE AT
FOCUSED ON KNOWINGLY
POSSESSING BECAUSE THERE IS
THE POTENTIAL SCENARIO WHERE
-- MECHANIC RECEIVE THE CAR
STARTS WORKING ON THAT CAR --
-- IS REALIZES THAT THEY
HAVE -- IS SHAVED OFF FOR
UNIDENTIFIED -- CATALYTIC
CONVERTER AS A PART OF THAT
CAR THAT THEY GO TO REPAIR
-- AND THEN DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO --
AT THE REPORTER REGISTER
OR INDICATE THAT THEY HAVE
THAT THEY ARE TECHNICALLY
IN KNOWING POSSESSION OF
OF A LIKELY STOLEN -- KIND
OF REPLACE PART SO I WOULD
LOVE FOR YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
IN ANY FUTURE AMENDMENTS I
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT
POTENTIAL SCENARIO WHICH
WOULD PUT THE SAME PEOPLE --
AS A PART OF THE INDUSTRY THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP SUPPORT
THEM IN IN IN IN A BAD WAY
I APPRECIATE THAT CONCERN
ALL CERTAINLY -- HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH BOTH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS THE --
-- DEALERS TO TRY FIGURE OUT
THE BEST SOLUTION AND I I
CAN TELL YOU IN MY DISTRICT
SPECIFICALLY -- I'VE SPOKEN WITH
MY LOCAL SHERIFF WHERE HE KNOWS
OF A BLACK MARKET OPERATION
RECYCLER AND EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE GOING WITH
THE PARTS AND NOBODY CAN REST
ANYBODY -- FOR POSSESSION OF
THE STOLEN PARTS BECAUSE OF THIS
LACK OF A VENN NUMBER OR SOME
WAY TO ASSOCIATE YOU KNOW THE
CRIME -- WITH THE ACTIVITY
-- BUT THAT'S A CERTAINLY A
WELL REASONED POINT NOW SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO TO ADDRESS
IT THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT A
SECOND THANK YOU FOR ANY
OF THE COMMENTS SIR MISTER LUCKY
AGAIN NOT TO STATE THE OBVIOUS
BUT -- FIRST OF ALL THIS IS
AS YOU INDICATED IF YOU'RE A
VICTIM OF THIS IT'S DEVASTATING
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING --
THE COST IS HUGELY BURDENSOME
I DON'T CARE WHAT YOUR LEVEL
OF INCOME AS AND ESPECIALLY IF
YOU'RE STRUGGLING AS THIS COULD
TAKE A TRANSPORTATION RIGHT OUT
OF THE PICTURE SO THIS A HUGE
HUGE PROBLEM I THINK STATEWIDE
AND THE LEVEL OF EPIDEMIC
PROPORTIONS I KNOW THAT THERE'S
A TASK FORCE IN MY COMMUNITY
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ADDRESS
THE SPECIFIC PROBLEM AND THEY'RE
HAVING MIXED SUCCESS --
SO THIS IS TRULY NEEDED HOWEVER
-- THE BURDENSOME MANDATE
AND AND THEN REASONABLENESS I
THINK YOU'VE ALREADY ADDRESSED
AND I WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY
BUT IF THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO --
GET THE BY AND WHEN IT COMES
THE FLOOR I'LL PROBABLY HAVE
A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE SO
I I COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FOR BECAUSE THIS REALLY
IS A POWERFUL PROBLEM AND --
I HOPE THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO
GET -- SOME REASONABLENESS
A LITTLE BETTER REASONABLENESS
FOR THE -- RESPONSIBLE
A CAR DEALERS -- AS A
PARTNER THANK YOU OUR
SUMMER THE -- OUR
TO ACKNOWLEDGE -- WILL FIRST
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE TODAY
-- AND WE WILL CERTAINLY WORK
DILIGENTLY TO COME TO SOME
REASONABLE AGREEMENT ON THOSE
DETAILS AND ALSO LIKE COMMITTEE
NOTICES IN THIS PARTICULAR
SUBJECT AREA -- IS A STATEWIDE
ISSUE OF CONCERN AS WE'VE HEARD
THIS AFTERNOON THIS AFTERNOON
-- I THINK THERE WAS OVER A
DOZEN BILLS INTRODUCED ON THIS
TOPIC MISTER AND -- I'M
PROUD TO SAY THIS BILL I THINK
-- IS MOVING -- SUBJECTION IS
BOTH BIPARTISAN AND WILL
ALLOW US TO READ -- ARRIVE
AT SOME CONSENSUS TRUST USES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE HERE TODAY
ANY OTHER COMMENTS YOU MAY CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AND AND I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR BECAUSE
WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF BILLS
LIKE THIS -- THIS IS THIS IS
A DEFINITELY A GOOD START --
ONLY THING I WOULD SUGGEST
-- IS THAT CAR MANUFACTURERS
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON DEALERS
AND EVERYBODY GET TOGETHER
ACTUALLY PROBABLY TO TALK TO
THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER THESE
BECAUSE THEY ARE ABLE TO GET
THESE THINGS OFTEN FOR MINUTES
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT TAKES
FOUR HOURS BUT MAYBE
IT ALL OF YOU GOT TOGETHER AND
TALKED ABOUT HOW TO GET IT OFF
SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY CATCH IT IN
-- THEY MAY BE -- SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS AT HOW TO GET
THESE THINGS OFF OF OF CARS IN A
THANK IN A QUICK WAY
SO -- I'M JUST PUTTING
THAT IN THERE -- SUGGEST
RECOMMEND AND I BOTH
MAY CALL THE ROLL ON AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY TWO BY SEVEN MEMBER
GRAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN
HI QUIRK QUIRK I SANTIAGO
SEYARTO THEY ARE TURNOUT
VOTING THAT MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU THANK MEASURE
THANK YOU MEMBERS --
I HAVE MR HOLDEN IN
MISTER MURATSUCHI HERE
MR HOLDEN WHICH FIRST
ON ON A THING UNLESS
YOU GUYS WANT TO FIGHT
IT OUT RIGHT HERE --
OR BILLS --
GOOD GOOD ANSWER MR MERCER JIM
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MR HOLD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A. B. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN ARE PROTECTED WHILE
THEY'RE A DAY AND SUMMER CAMPS
THIS COMING SUMMER CHILDREN
FROM ALL OVER CALIFORNIA WILL
ATTEND THOUSANDS OF CAMPS OF
THESE CAMPS ONLY OVERNIGHT
CAMPS ARE REQUIRED TO FOLLOW
STATE REGULATIONS IN VIRTUALLY
NONE ARE INSPECTED TO ENSURE
THAT'S SO THAT THE SAFETY OF
CHILDREN ATTENDING INSPECTIONS
THAT ARE CARRIED OUT DO NOT
FOCUS ON STAFF QUALIFICATIONS
OR BACKGROUND CHECKS BUT INSTEAD
ARE PRIMARILY CONCENTRATED
ON BUILDING AND FOOD COME CODE
COMPLIANCE DECAMPS ATTENDED
BY CHILDREN WHICH CONSTITUTE
THE VAST MAJORITIES OF CAMPS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO FOLLOW ANY REGULATIONS OR
LAWS REGARDING CHILD SAFETY
INCLUDING SEX OFFENDER IN
BACKGROUND CHECKS THIS BILL
WILL ADDRESS THESE DEFICIENCIES
IN CURRENT LAW BY REQUIRING
CHILDREN'S CAMPS TO ADOPT BASIC
SAFETY STANDARDS AND CONDUCT
ANNUAL BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR ALL
PROSPECTIVE AND CURRENT STAFF
MANY PREVENTABLE TRAGEDIES WE
HAVE SEEN AT CAMPS INDICATED
THAT WE MUST DO MORE TO PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN IN THE CASE OF
ROCKS A FOUR TO SIX YEAR OLD
WHO DROWNED WHILE ATTENDING
THE DAY CAMPING OUT TO DINNER
THESE PROTECTIONS WILL BE TOO
LATE BUT IT'S NOT TOO LATE
TO PREVENT FUTURE CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES FROM
SUFFERING THIS HEARTBREAKING
EXPERIENCE HERE WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS
DOUG FORD'S THE FATHER OF ROXY
THANK YOU YES FIVE MINUTES SIR
THANK YOU I WANNA THANK MEMBER
HOLDEN AND HIS TEAM FOR THEIR
PERSEVERANCE ON THIS CRITICAL
MATTER AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR LISTENING
MY NAME IS DOUG FORBES THIS
IS MY WIFE ELENA AND MY SIX
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER ROXY DESPITE
THAT I NOW LIVE IN AN EMPTY
HOUSE ON A HILL IN PASADENA
THAT'S BECAUSE AN UNREGULATED
UNLICENSED SUMMER CAMP KILLED MY
SIX ROLE DAUGHTER ROXY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND SEVEN WEEKS AGO MY
BELOVED WIFE DIED OF CANCER AT
AGE FIFTY FUEL BY UNRELENTING
DESPAIR IN THE WAKE OF OUR
DAUGHTERS WHOLLY PREVENTABLE
DEATH THE CAMP UP READERS THAT
KILLED MY DAUGHTER HAVE SINCE
ADMITTED TO FRAUDULENT AND
GROSSLY NEGLIGENT ACTS THAT
LED TO HER DEATH YET THEY NEVER
HAD TO STOP OPERATING INCLUDING
THE VERY DAY THEY KILLED ROXY
I STILL HEAR ROXY DEMANDING GUN
CONTROL OR CHANTING QUOTE KEEP
OUR FAMILIES TOGETHER HONOR TWO
MILE MARK FOR IMMIGRATION RIGHTS
I HEAR ELENA READING TO ROCK THE
SPANISH IMMERSION KINDERGARTEN
CLASS I HEAR THE THREE OF
US EXCHANGING I LOVE YOUS AD
INFINITUM THERE'S NOTHING LIKE
STANDING OVER YOUR CHILD WITH
HER I STUCK HALF OPEN PEOPLE'S
BLACK SKIN COLD AND BLUE GOLDEN
HAIR STUFF THE STRAW BEFORE I
LEFT ROCKS IN A HOSPITAL BED I
PROMISED HER I WOULD NOT STOP
UNTIL I PREVENTED OTHER CHILDREN
IN FAMILIES FROM SUFFERING THE
WAY WE HAVE IN FACT I MADE THAT
VERY SAME PROMISE TO MY WIFE AS
SHE TOOK HER FINAL BREATHS TWO
WEEKS AFTER I MADE THAT PROMISE
ROCKS HE MY WIFE AND I LAUNCHED
THE NATION'S ONLY CAMP SAFETY
FOUNDATION TWO MONTHS AFTER
THAT MY WIFE AND I WERE BUSY
WORKING ON OUR FIRST CAMP SAFETY
BILL AND A FEW MONTHS AFTER
THAT A COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISOR
WROTE IN OPPOSITION LETTER
TO THE ASSEMBLY AS DID OTHER
COUNTIES IN COUNTY HEALTH LOBBY
GROUPS IN CAMP LOBBY GROUPS
THE BOARD SUPERVISORS SAID
QUOTE OUR HEALTH DEPARTMENT IS
NOT EQUIPPED TO OVERSEE CHILD
SAFETY AND WELLBEING DESPITE
HAVING ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURES WHICH INCLUDE
KEEP INCLUDED KEEPING CHILDREN
SAFE A COMPLEX CARNIVALS OUTDOOR
FESTIVALS IN AQUATICS FACILITIES
THESE AGENCIES LOOK AT ME IN
THE RESOURCES I DON'T HAVE A
FAMILY I DON'T HAVE AND DESPITE
WHAT I DON'T HAVE I STOP AT
NOTHING TO PREVENT FAMILIES
FROM SUFFERING AS I DO THE OTHER
PROBLEM WITH SUCH OPPOSITION
IS THAT COUNTIES ESSENTIALLY
ADMITTED TO THE ASSEMBLY THAT
THEY ARE DISREGARDING THE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE ORGANIZED
CAMP LAW WHICH IS WOEFULLY
DEFICIENT AS IT IS NONETHELESS
REQUIRES THEM TO ENFORCE SIMPLE
SAFETY MEASURES RELATED TO
CAPS THE SAME ORGANIZED CAMP
LAW ALSO STATES THAT THE BOY
SCOUTS OF AMERICA IS QUOTE A
TRUE PROTOTYPE OF AN ORGANIZED
CAMP YES THE SAME BOY SCOUTS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE WORST CHILD
MOLESTATION CAMPAIGN IN U. S.
HISTORY USING COUNTLESS CAMPS
THE BOY SCOUTS ARE HARDLY ALONE
THIRTEEN CHILDREN MOLESTED AT
THE PAINTED TURTLE CAMP FOR
SERIOUSLY ILL CHILDREN IN L.
A. COUNTY SIXTEEN GIRLS UNDER
EIGHT SEVEN MOLESTED AT THE
FIRST BAPTIST CHURCH CAMP IN
SAN JOSE THE DEATH OF A CHILD
HERE AT CAMP SACRAMENTO WHICH
COST TAXPAYERS FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN FACT I KNOW OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO DIED OR NEARLY DIED
AT FOUR DIFFERENT CAMPS FIFTEEN
MINUTES FROM MY HOUSE THERE'S
WIDESPREAD SEXUAL CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE AND HARM ITS CITY CAMP
SCHOOL CAMPS SCIENCE CAMPS
CHRISTIAN CAMPS YMCA CAMPS AND
CAMPS ACCREDITED BY OR MEMBERS
OF THE AMERICAN CAMP ASSOCIATION
THAT'S BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF ONLY TWELVE STATES THAT
DOES NOT LICENSE DAY CAMPS
AND I'VE YET TO SEE COUNTIES
AFFORD MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT
OF OVERNIGHT CAMPS CALIFORNIA
HIGHLY REGULATES DAYCARE
OPERATIONS WITH FINGER PAINTING
AND SINGALONGS IT CALIFORNIA
CAMPS HAVE VERY YOUNG CHILDREN
SHOOTING LIVE ROUNDS FROM TWENTY
TWO CALIBER RIFLES AND BOUNCING
ON ROPES A HUNDRED FEET HIGH
WITHOUT AN OUNCE OF REGULATION
TO PROTECT THEM THIS STATE DOES
NOT REQUIRE CERTIFICATIONS FOR
CAMPS TO OPERATE THOSE HIGH
RISK ACTIVITIES OR REQUIRE
BACKGROUND CHECKS TO PREVENT
MOLD A STATIONS OR EMERGENCY
ACTION PLANS TO PREPARE FOR
ACTIVE SHOOTERS FIRES ARE COVERT
OUTBREAKS OR REQUIRE TRAINED
HEALTH SUPERVISORS OR EVEN
MEANINGFUL SAFETY INSPECTIONS
I NOW RUN THE NATION'S ONLY
CAMP SAFETY FOUNDATION OUR
ALLIANCES INCLUDE THE BEAU BIDEN
FOUNDATION AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO NAME A FEW WE SUCCESSFULLY
PASSED CAMP SAFETY LEGISLATION
IN L. A. COUNTY IMPACTING TEN
MILLION RESIDENTS AND I ASK
THAT THE STATE DOES THE SAME
I'VE WITNESSED THE TOLD US
HARM ALSO TAKES ON THE WHOLE
ROAD POLICE AND FIREFIGHTERS
AND MEDICAL FOLKS THAT I SPEAK
WITH THEY MUST TAKE PAINFUL
MEMORIES OF THIS PREVENTABLE
OF THESE PREVENTABLE INCIDENTS
HOME TO THEIR OWN FAMILIES
HARD WORKING FAMILIES NEED TO
PUT THEIR KIDS IN CAMPS BECAUSE
CANCER CHILD CARE FACILITIES
BUT THEY NEED TO KNOW THEIR
KIDS ARE PROPERLY PROTECTED
FROM SEXUAL ABUSE AND INJURY
AND DEATH MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE BRAVELY OVERCOME
LONG ODDS TO BE WHERE THEY ARE
TODAY AND THAT'S WHAT I AM NOW
ATTEMPTING IN THE FACE OF MY
DAUGHTER'S KILLING MY WIFE'S
DEATH MY STRUGGLE TO GET UP
EACH MORNING I'M HERE FOR YOUR
CHILDREN FOR YOUR CHILDREN'S
CHILDREN AND YOUR COMMUNITIES
CHILDREN ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
CALIFORNIA IS BETTER THAN THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE SECOND
SEEING NONE AT&T OPERATOR
YOU CAN GO TO PHONE LINES
WITNESSES AND SECURITY ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONCE AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THERE ARE
AND WE GOT ONLINE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING OUT OF FEDERAL
PRISON LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND RIGHT THANK YOU YOU
M. LINE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU YES
A GREAT MORNING CHURCH REMEMBERS
HOW MUCH BETTER THAN INSURANCE
YOU'RE PROBABLY RUNNING
FOR U. S. SENATE WE AREN'T
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THANK YOU
CONNECTED ONLINE SEVENTY EIGHT
GOOD MORNING MR HOLDEN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KERRY MCCARTY I AM A CONCERNED
MOTHER FROM PASADENA AND MY
SON'S BEST FRIEND WAS ROCKED
BEFORE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN ORDER TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AT CAMP THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT ON
THE LINE FORTY SEVEN
I AM GERALD FORD
GRANDMOTHER OF ROCKY FORD
WHO'S PREVENTABLE DROWNING
DEATH HAS DEVASTATED DAY
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
SO THAT OTHER CHILDREN WILL
BE SAVED FROM THESE HORRIBLE
PREVENTABLE YES I DO SUPPORT
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AND NO ONE WAITING IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE WE WILL NOW
GO TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF BETSY ARMSTRONG WITH
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN HERE AND I'M
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE JACK WOULD LIKE TO
COMMEND ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLD
GOAL TO CREATE AN OVERSIGHT
AND ENFORCEMENT STRUCTURE FOR
CHILDREN'S CAMPS THAT ENSURES
THE SAFETY AND WELL BEING FOR
CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE WELL
WE AGREE WITH THE GOAL WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH HOW
THE BILL SEEKS TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
PROTECT COMMUNITIES FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH THREATS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO INFECTIOUS DISEASES
FOOD BORNE ILLNESSES AND CHRONIC
DISEASE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
DO NOT HAVE THE EXPERTISE IN
CHILD SUPERVISION AND PLACING
THE OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSIBILITY OF CHILDREN'S
CAMPS WITH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WILL FALL SHORT OF
THE INTENDED GOAL AND WOULD NOT
PROVIDE SAFER ENVIRONMENTS FOR
CHILDREN WE'VE APPRECIATED THE
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE TO DATE AND CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO INSTEAD
PLACE THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
CHILDREN'S CAMPS WITH AN AGENCY
WITH APPROPRIATE EXPERIENCE IN
THE OVERSIGHT OF ENTITIES WITH
CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE SUCH
AS THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES CDSS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO MEETING WITH
CDSS THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TOMORROW
AND HOPE THAT AS A RESULT THE
BILL WILL BE AMENDED TO REFLECT
THIS MORE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
STRUCTURE CDSS HAS A COMMUNITY
CARE LICENSING DIVISION THAT
LICENSES VARIOUS FACILITIES
TO PROVIDE CARE TO CHILDREN
INCLUDING CHILD CARE FACILITIES
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE CONSISTS OF
THREE MAIN COMPONENTS PREVENTION
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT
ACCORDING TO CDSS THROUGH
PREVENTION THEY REDUCE THE
PREDICTABLE HARM TO CHILDREN BY
PROVIDING AN ORIENTATION PRIOR
TO LICENSURE PERFORM BACKGROUND
CHECKS MAINTAIN STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS HEALTH SCREENINGS
PRE LICENSURE INSPECTIONS
AND PROVIDING INFORMATION
REGARDING LAWS AND REGULATIONS
IN TERMS OF COMPLIANCE
THIS IS MAINTAINED THROUGH
UNANNOUNCED FACILITY INSPECTIONS
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATIONS
ISSUING DEFICIENCY NOTICES
THE CONSULTATIONS EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT AND FOLLOW UP LASTLY
ENFORCEMENT IS TAKEN WHEN THE
ENTITY FAILS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND PERSONAL
RIGHTS OF CHILDREN IN CARE OR IS
UNWILLING TO MAINTAIN COMPLIANCE
WITH LAWS AND REGULATIONS THIS
IS DONE THROUGH CIVIL PENALTIES
AND OR ADMINISTRATIVE LEGAL
ACTION SUCH AS TO NILES ABOUT
LOCATIONS PROBATIONARY LICENSES
SUSPENSIONS OR REVOCATION OF A
LICENCE AND LICENSEE AN EMPLOYEE
EXCLUSIONS THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
IS FAR MORE SUITED TO PROTECT
THE SAFETY OF CHILDREN ATTENDING
DAY CAMPS WHERE IS OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS INSTEAD
FOCUS ON PROTECTING COMMUNITIES
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS
ARE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL
BE OPERATING OUTSIDE OF THEIR
EXPERTISE AND IN ADDITION WOULD
NEED TO ACQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
WORK FORCE AT A TIME WHEN
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
ALREADY LOSING STAFF DUE TO
LACK OF ON GOING FUNDING AND
EVEN MORE SO BURN OUT HARASSMENT
AND THREATS EXPERIENCED DURING
OUR LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
DO NOT BELIEVE THIS PROPOSED
OVERSIGHT STRUCTURE PUTS THE
SAFETY OF CHILDREN FIRST AND
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MIKE STILSON AND
YOU CHECK YOUR DOCTOR ABOUT
ACTUAL SUMMER CAMP OPERATE TWO
LOCATIONS ARE CALIFORNIA BOTH
OF WHICH ARE PERMITTED BY THE
L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND A WHOLE TOLD SKIPS
PERMITS FOR THOSE IN ADDITION
TO THAT I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
THE WESTERN SOCIUS UNIT AND
INDEPENDENT CAMPUS AND I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION FOR YOUTH FIRST
ONE'S REPORTERS ROCKS YOU WILL
NOT BE FORGOTTEN AS A PROFESSION
THE CAMP INDUSTRY MY JOB IS TO
ENSURE THAT MY STAFF ARE WHERE
THE DANGER THE CAMP AND FOR THE
PAST TWO SUMMERS I'VE OPERATED
I'VE SHARED HER STORY TO THE
BEST OF MY ABILITY TO ENSURE
THAT THE UNDERSTAND THE GRAVE
NATURE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
SAFETY IN OUR CAMP PROGRAMS
SHE WOULD NOT BE FORGOTTEN THE
THE PROBLEM IS WE HAVE TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
THE CAMP PROFESSIONALS THE
INDUSTRY HAS NOT BEEN INVOLVED
IN THIS PROCESS THE DEFINITION
OF WHAT IS INCLUDED IN THIS BILL
AS WRITTEN INVOLVES WAY TOO MANY
PROGRAMS ARE CLEARLY NOT CAMPS
EDUCATION BIBLE SCHOOLS YOUTH
GROUPS ATHLETIC GROUPS THESE ARE
CLEARLY NOT DAY CAMPS DAY CAMPS
ARE HERE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
GROWING KIDS IN A SAFE AND WARM
WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS CAN BE DONE
IS IN THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
WITH SOME MINOR CHANGES AS WELL
WE WANT TO BE PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION WE WANT SMART WE
WANT SENSIBLE REGULATION WE
WANT THIS THIS IS WHAT THE
CAMP INDUSTRY'S BEEN ASKING
FOR FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS WE'VE
BEEN ASKING TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE YORK ORGANIZED CAMP ACT
WE WANT TO KEEP KIDS SAFE WE
WANT OUR FAMILIES TO HAVE THEIR
CHILDREN GO HOME DIRTY AND
TIRED AND FULL OF MEMORIES EVERY
SINGLE DAY THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
DEDICATED TO THAT'S WHY SPENT
THIRTY FOUR MIGHT THIRTY FOUR
YEARS OF MY LIFE DOING SO FAR
AT THIS POINT THE WAY THIS BILL
AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN IT SHOULD
ALSO INCLUDE THE AMERICAN CAMP
ASSOCIATION STANDARDS THERE
ARE THREE UNDER STANDARDS
WHICH ARE CONSIDERED THE GOLD
STANDARD WITH IN THE NATION
THIS WILL HELP TO ENSURE THAT
THE CONGREGATION CAN BE DONE
IT COULD BE DONE PROPERLY AND
EXPECT EXPEDITIOUSLY THE WAY
THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
WITH THE NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS
WE BROUGHT INTO THIS ENVELOPE
IS OVER TENS OF THOUSANDS
UNINTENDED GROUPS THAT WILL HAVE
TO BE INSPECTED NO ONE NOT THE
DEPARTMENT SOLDIERS SERVICES NOT
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT THERE'S
NOT A SINGLE SINGLE REGULATORY
BODY THE STATE THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO ENSURE THE CANCER SAFE
IF THEY HAVE TO INSPECT THIS
MANY PROGRAMS THAT ARE CLEARLY
NOT A CAMPUS AT THIS POINT WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE CONVERSATION WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR WORK WITH MR FORBES AND
BE INVOLVED IN THIS BECAUSE
ONCE AGAIN WE WANT CAMPUS
TO BE SAFE WE WANT CHILDREN
TO GO HOME SAFE THANK YOU
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING
ROOM NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ON THE ASSEMBLY DOES ON
BEHALF OF THE TRI VALLEY CITIES
OF DUBLIN LIVERMORE PLEASANTON
SAN RAMON AND DANVILLE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH HAS
BEEN -- SOME BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA A WE ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE BY CHIA THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES EIGHTEEN ANTI OPERATORS
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN HOLD ON
OKAY IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME LINE EIGHTY
GOOD MORNING CARE NUMBERS GAME
HAS CHANGED RIGHT PUBLIC POLICY
GROUP RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION ON
BEHALF OF CITIZENS BAKER STEEL'S
BELMONT CARLSBAD AND REDWOOD
CITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU NINE SEVEN SEVEN
HELLO TURN MEMBERS KILLING
TURNS YANNI ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
FOR MAINTAINING OUR CONCERN
TECHNICIAN ON AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN AT THIS TIME I
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR ADOPTED TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU
NINE THIRTY SEVEN
THE BIRD WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA JOINING A
COLLEAGUE THAT YAKKING
RESPECTS OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION
ONCE AGAIN OF AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
I AM NOT SEEING ANY ADDITIONAL
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU AND I'LL BRING
IT TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NOT -- MISTER BRYANT
I JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND FOR ALL
OF THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
I AM VERY SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS I DEFINITELY HAVE THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS AND I
DON'T KNOW A MORE COLLABORATIVE
OR THOUGHTFUL AUTHOR IN THIS
BUILDING AND SO I HAVE ALL THE
FULL CONFIDENCE THAT THIS WILL
CONTINUE AFFORD IN A GOOD WAY
-- AND YOU HAVE MY SUPPORT TODAY
RESPOND TO ECHO
THOSE COMMENTS CAME
EIGHT YOU MAY CLOSE
FIRST OF ALL I APPRECIATE --
AS I'VE SAID MANY TIMES --
DOUG FORBES COURAGE AND
-- BUT
YOU KNOW IT'S TOUGH
POSITION THAT THAT IS IN
-- BUT IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
LOVE FOR HIS FAMILY THAT
HE HAS IN THE PROMISES
THAT HE CAP THESE PREPARE
TO KEEP THAT IS HERE TODAY
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON --
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT NOT JUST TO HIM AND
CERTAINLY THE PASSION AND THE
EMOTIONS THAT HAVE RIVETED
ALL OF US IN HIS PRESENTATION
-- BUT IT'S FOR A LOT OF OTHER
CHILDREN OUT THERE WHO ARE
EXPOSED IN AN INDUSTRY THAT IS
NOT REGULATED AS IT SHOULD BE
AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION'S WILLINGNESS TO --
WORK WITH US -- BECAUSE I
THINK WE WERE WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO A WAY TO --
TO LAND THIS PLANE WHERE
THE END RESULT ACCOMPLISHES
THE GOALS OF MAKING
SURE THAT CHILDREN RETURNED
SAFELY TO THEIR THEIR PARENTS
-- AND I THINK THAT
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING THERE -- IT
WITHOUT OUR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU AND I ALSO
THINK THIS TO FORCE TO BRING
THE SUPPORT OF IT'S NOT OFTEN
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL -- BRINGS
TO THE STATE'S ATTENTION ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT KIND OF FELL
THROUGH THE CRACKS WE DIDN'T
KNOW THERE WASN'T ANY ANY
REGULATION TO TO THE POINT
THAT IT NEEDS IT NEEDED TO BE
-- BUT MORE IMPORTANT WHAT I'M
NOT HEARING IS UP FROM EITHER
SIDE THAT YOU SHOULDN'T BE
REGULATION I THINK EVERYBODY
AGREES WE NEED SOME TYPE
OF REGULATION SOME TYPE OF
OVERSIGHT WE NEED TO BUILD A
STRUCTURE SAID A REINSURER TO
SAFETY EVERYONE WE MAY
DISAGREE ON IMPLEMENTATION BUT
WE DON'T DISAGREE THAT THIS
NEEDS TO BE DONE AT MIDNIGHT I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES DEAD
ON YOUR AUTHOR IS ONE THAT
CAN BRING THIS ON HOLD OF TO
ENSURE THAT WE WE WE GET THIS
DONE CHECKS RECOMMENDED I BOTH
ON AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
BASE A MEMBER HOLDEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER DJOSER
IRAQI LACKEY NOT VOTING
BONTA BONTA I BRIAN
BRIAN I COURT COURT
HI SAN DIEGO SEYARTO
C. R. THEY'RE NOT VOTING
IMAGES ON CALL NEEDS ONE MORE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
BUT I HATE THIS SO
MR RESEARCH IF YOU DON'T MIND
RESEARCH ABOUT THIS MR RESEARCH
HAS BEEN WAITING FOR A WHILE IF
YOU DON'T MIND IF YOU GO BACK
A DEEP DID DOES SHE
NEED TO BE SOME MORE
DO YOU
OKAY OKAY
SO
IF YEAH
CERVANTES WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY TO BEGIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
EIGHT COMMONSENSE MEASURE TO
PROTECT SURVIVORS ARE CRIMINAL
STOCKING FROM RE TRAUMATIZE
ATION AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SIMPLY PROTECT SURVIVORS FROM
RETIREMENT HESITATION SO THEY
DO NOT HAVE TO ANSWER DIRECT
QUESTIONING FROM THE SAME
PERSON WHO HAS ALLEGEDLY BEEN
STALKING THEM INSTEAD THIS
NARROW BILL RIGHTFULLY CENTERS
THE EXPERIENCE OF SURVIVORS
OF STOCKING BY ALLOWING THEM
TO TESTIFY REMOTELY UNDER VERY
LIMITED SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
FIRST THE DEFENDANT MUST BE
ACTING IN PRO PER OR IN OTHER
WORDS DEFENDING THEMSELVES
WITHOUT AN ATTORNEY THIS IS VERY
UNCOMMON AS YOU KNOW THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS
RECEIVE THE ASSISTANCE OF
COUNSEL SECOND TO THE JUDGE
WOULD HAVE TO FIND THAT HAVING
TO TESTIFY IN A COURT ROOM
WOULD HAVE TO SO SUBSTANTIAL
HAVING A SUBSTANTIAL EFFECT ON
THE SURVIVOR THAT THEY WOULD
BE UNAVAILABLE AS A WITNESS
UNLESS THEY ARE ABLE TO TESTIFY
REMOTELY TO THAT END WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT ON THE
SURVIVOR IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE WERE STATE THE ELEMENTS
OF CRIMINAL STALKING FIRST
THE DEFENDANT IS ALLEGED TO
HAVE REPEATEDLY HARASSED OR
FOLLOWED THE SURVIVOR SECOND
THE PERPETRATOR ALLEGEDLY
MADE A CREDIBLE THREAT PLACING
THE SURVIVOR IN FEAR OF THEIR
SAFETY OR THE SAFETY OF THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE
BEEN REPEATEDLY HARASSED OR
FOLLOWED BY A STRANGER AND
THEN THREATENED BY THAT PERSON
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL HAVING TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM THAT
SAME PERSON WELL THEY WERE
STANDING JUST A FEW FEET
AWAY FROM YOU IN A COURT ROOM
NO ONE SHOULD BE FORCED TO
GO THROUGH THAT NOW LET'S
TURN TO WHETHER REMOTE
TESTIMONY IS ALLOWABLE UNDER
THE SIXTH AMENDMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION
THE ANSWER IS CLEARLY YES
THE CASE LAW BOTH THE PRIM
CORE OF THE UNITED STATES IN
OUR OWN STATE COURT IS VERY
CLEAR REMOTE TESTIMONY IS
PERMISSIBLE UNDER THE SIXTH
AMENDMENT SO LONG AS REMOTE
TESTIMONY WILL FULFILL AN
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY INTEREST
SO THE IMPORTANT QUESTION
POSED TO THIS COMMITTEE BY AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY IS THIS IS
PROTECTING SURVIVORS A CRIMINAL
STALKING AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
POLICY INTEREST IN CALIFORNIA
AGAIN I BELIEVE THAT ANSWER
EMPATHETICALLY IS YES INDEED
AND MANY OTHER LEGAL CONTACTS
IT IS APPARENT THAT OUR STATE
HAS ALREADY FOUND THE STATE
INTEREST TO BE COMPELLING FOR
INSTANCE ANYTIME A CALIFORNIA
COURT ISSUES A PROTECTIVE ORDER
AGAINST STALKER IT RESTRICTS
THE RIGHTS OF THE PERPETRATOR
TO PROTECT THE SURVIVOR FROM
FURTHER AND WANTED CONTACT
JUST AS WE ALLOW OUR COURTS
TO ISSUE PROTECTIVE ORDERS TO
PROTECT SURVIVORS THIS BILL
SEEKS TO DO THE SAME THING IN A
COURTROOM IN ADDITION THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY IN THIS BILL IS NOT
AN INNOVATION FOR TWO REASONS
FIRST EXISTING LAW ALREADY
ALLOWS MINORS AGES THIRTEEN
YEARS OF AGE AND YOUNGER TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY IN CASES WHICH
THEY ARE SURVIVORS OR WITNESSES
TO SEXUAL ASSAULT OR VIOLENT
FELONIES AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINETY ACTUALLY USES THE SAME
PROCEDURES AS THIS EXISTING LAW
SECOND BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC REMOTE
TESTIMONY BECAME COMMONPLACE IN
OUR CRIMINAL COURTS IF THIS
BILL IS ENACTED THE DEFENDANT
ACTED IN PRO PER WE'LL STILL
GET TO ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
SURVIVOR AND GET LIVE RESPONSES
AS WELL AS A CHANCE TO POSE
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS EVEN
IF THE SURVIVOR IS TESTIFIED
REMOTELY THE BILL REQUIRES THAT
THE DEFENDANT IS STILL ABLE
TO SEE THE FACE AND REACTION
OF THE SURVIVOR DURING THEIR
TESTIMONY LET ME ADDRESS
THE ARGUMENTS PROVIDED
BY THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
PAGE EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS
PURPORTS TO PROVIDE SUPPOSED
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS ALREADY
AVAILABLE TO THE COURT HOWEVER
THERE IS A FLAW IN WENT IN THOSE
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS THERE ARE
REACTIVE MEASURES THEY ALL
REQUIRE THE DEFENDANT ACTING IN
PRO PER TO ACTIVELY ACTIVELY
BEGAN HARASSING THE SURVIVOR
FOR A JUDGE TO STEP IN AND
ACT WE SHOULD NOT BE IN THE
BUSINESS OF ALLOWING A DEFENDANT
TO ENGAGE IN ANY HARASSMENT
OR SURVIVOR A CRIMINAL STOCKY
INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR THE
DEFENDANT TO HARASS THE SURVIVOR
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY PROVIDES
PROACTIVE PROACTIVE PROTECTIONS
TO SURVIVOR SO THEY COULD NOT
BE HARASSED IN THE FIRST PLACE
COLLEAGUES THERE'S NO SUCH THING
AS A MILD RE TRAUMATIZE ATION
SURVIVORS ARE EITHER TRAUMATIZED
AGAIN BY BEING HARASSED
BY THEIR ALLEGED STALKER
OR THEY ARE NOT THIS BILL
SENDS US WITH AN OPPORTUNITY
TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON ALL OF
OUR SPEECHES ABOUT PROTECTING
SURVIVORS AND I HOPE YOU WILL
JOIN ME IN ACTING TO PROTECT
THEM FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS JUDY TENSIONER
TENSIONER WITH SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER STEPHAN
IS OFFICE AS WELL AS AUDREY B.
THANK YOU UP AT&T OPERATOR
KEY OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR BOTH OF THE WITNESSES
WINDS ARE OPEN
THE STATURE OR STOCKING
WHICHEVER ONE WAS TO BEGIN FIRST
WELL THANK YOU THIS IS THAT
MISS JUDY TASCHNER I'M A
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY AT
THE SAN DIEGO DA'S OFFICE
AND -- GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CERVANTES FOR THAT GREAT SUMMARY
ABOUT THIS BILL -- I HAVE
I HAVE BEEN IN RECEIPT OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT'S BEEN FILED
TO THIS -- VERY IMPORTANT AND
NARROWLY TERREL TAILORED BILL
AND THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF
THIS SHOULD NOT BE IN DISPUTE
THERE IS A WELL SETTLED LAW
THAT THIS IS A LOUD -- A U.
S. SUPREME COURT CASE MARILYN
B. CRAIG A CALIFORNIA CASE OF
PEOPLE V. LU CHEN ON NUMEROUS
STATE -- HAVE ENACTED LAWS
THAT PROTECT -- BREAK DOWN
AND READ AND ALLOW THEM TO
TESTIFY VIA CCTV THE IMPORTANT
THING TO FOCUS ON AND WHY
THIS IS ALLOWED AND WHY IT IS
CONSTITUTIONAL IF WHAT ARE BILL
ALREADY PROVIDES WHICH SHOWS
THAT THERE IS AN IMPORTANT
PUBLIC POLICY INTEREST IN
PROTECTING STALKING VICTIMS AND
THEN THE SECOND THING IS THERE
HAS TO BE A FINDING THAT IT IS
NECESSARY IN THAT PARTICULAR
CASE AND SO THAT IS ALREADY
BUILT INTO OUR PENAL CODE
PENAL CODE SECTION THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN -- THOSE FACTIONS
THAT ALREADY WE HAVE -- THAT
APPLIED FOR OTHER VICTIMS WE
ARE SIMPLY MIRRORING THOSE
SAME REQUIREMENTS AND SO WE ARE
ALREADY HEARING TO THE RULES WE
ARE HEARING TO THE CONSTITUTION
AND WE ARE REQUESTING A VERY
NARROW EXCEPTION FOR A GROUP
OF VICTIMS ON WHO ARE NOT
INCLUDED AND THIS PROTECTION
IS NECESSARY BECAUSE STOCKING
IS ONE OF THE MOST EMOTIONALLY
AND PSYCHOLOGICALLY TRAUMATIZING
CRIMES THAT CAN RESULT IN
LASTING IMPACTS AFTER THE
ACTUAL TIME CRIME HAS BEEN
COMMITTED AND IT INHERENTLY
INHERENTLY REQUIRES THAT THE
VICTIMS HAD BEEN TRAUMATIZED
ALREADY BASED ON THE DEFENDANT'S
ACTIONS AND UNWANTED CONTACT
SO -- WITH ME HERE TODAY --
AND BEFORE -- BEFORE SHE DID SHE
SPEAK I JUST DID WANT TO SAY THE
OPPOSITION THEY HAVE FILED CASE
LAW AGAINST THIS AND I I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR THAT
THOSE CASES ARE DISTINGUISHED
-- BECAUSE AS LONG AS YOU HAVE
THAT NECESSARY FINDING THAT
REQUIREMENT THAT IT IS NECESSARY
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE WHICH
WE DO THEN IT CAN BE APPLIED
-- IT IS IT IS CONSTITUTIONAL
TO ALLOW ALLOW THIS PROTECTION
AND IN OUR CASE -- THIS DOES
NOT JUST APPLY ANY TIME WE
WANT YOU THERE HAVE TO BE A
SPECIFIC FINDING THAT THIS
WITNESS WOULD STOP HER SERIES
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS AND WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BE UNAVAILABLE AS
A WITNESS IF THEY WERE GOING TO
BE REQUIRED TO HAVE TO TESTIFY
IN FRONT OF THIS DEFENDANT AND
SO THAT IS A VERY VERY HIGH
BURDEN IT HAS TO BE SHOWN BY
CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE
SO TO SAY THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE OPENING THE DOORS -- IS
JUST IT IT DOES NOT TRUE AND
IT IS CONSTITUTIONAL AND IS
ALREADY BUILT INTO THE STATUTE
AND WE HAVE WITH US HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT -- ADDS OF SO MANY
OTHER VICTIMS OF STALKING THAT
I HAD SPOKEN WITH IN THAT I'VE
HANDLED CASES WITH -- BUT SHE'S
JUST ONE OF THEM WHO'S WILLING
TO SPEAK TODAY -- HER NAME IS
AUDREY LAST INITIAL BE AND SHE
IS HERE ON A ON THE OTHER LINE
AS WELL IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU
AN AUDREY I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU CAN HEAR US OR IF YOU
CAN IF YOU CAN GET ON NOW
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AUDREY B. AND
I HAVE BEEN A VICTIM OF ASKING
FOR OVER THREE YEARS TALKING
IS AN EMOTIONALLY TRAUMATIC TYPE
OF CRIME FOR YOUR SAFETY AND
PEACE OF MIND FEEL THREATENED
I HAVE BEEN TREATED FOR PTSD
OF THE RESULT OF STOCKING AND
I'VE HAD A LITTLE AND REJECT
MY LIFESTYLE IN ORDER TO FEEL
SAFE THE DOCTOR OFTEN KNOWS
THIS INFLUENCE THEY HOLD AND
IN TURN MANIPULATE AND HARASSED
VICTIM DOCTORS ARE OFTEN
MENTALLY UNSTABLE ILLUSION ALL
AND UNPREDICTABLE AND BECOME
VERY FIXATED AND OBSESSED AND
WILL DO ANYTHING TO SEE OR
TALK TO THEIR VICTIM CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE SHOULD FIND THIS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY TO
PROTECT STALKING VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS IN COURT BY EMPOWERING
THEM WITH THE POTENTIAL OPTION
IN ORDER TO FEEL SAFE AND NOT
HAVE TO BE IN THE SAME ROOM AS
THEIR SOCCER I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF STOCKING SURVIVORS
AS A SURVIVOR MYSELF AND
AWARE OF THE IMPACT FIRST
WHY WOULD HELP PROTECT OTHERS
LIKE ME IN OUR COURT SYSTEM
I AM IT'S PART OF THE CELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE AT&T
OPERATOR IN A BLIND
IN A ROOM HIM STONE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM AND SUPPORT
BEFORE WE GO TO AT&T OPERATOR
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATE OPEN THE
LINE FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
THAT IS ONE DENNIS HERO TO
SUPPORT AB ONE SEVEN NINE ZERO
AND FIRST WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING SURE HOLDEN --
YOUR MEMBERS WHEN YOU MENTION
A LUNCHEON -- ONLY BRADLEY
RUNNING FOR THE SENATE WE ARE
ON SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU
AND I HAVE NO ANNOUNCED IN
Q. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THE CAB MARGO GEORGE SPURTS
CPD A TESTIFYING IN PERSON
AND MY GOD DR OFF --
ACLU TESTIFYING IN PERSON
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES TOTAL
GOOD MORNING AGAIN -- MY NAME
IS MARCO GEORGIAN I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO SEVENTEEN NINETY
-- FIRST I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THE CASE LAW THAT HAS BEEN
CITED ON TALKS ABOUT CHILDREN
AND THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO WIN
FAMILY LIVES ADULT VICTIMS
AND A QUITE THERE A TRAUMA
OR -- THERE THE
NEED TO PROTECT THEM TO BE THE
SAME AS WHAT HAS BEEN UTILIZED
WITH MINORS WHO ARE THIRTEEN
AND UNDER THE SIXTH AMENDMENT
GUARANTEES THE RIGHT TO SELF
REPRESENTATION ON THE PERSON
WHO'S ACCUSED OF THE CRIME
HAS THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO
REPRESENT HIMSELF OR HERSELF
UNDER FOR RATHER FOR OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY YEARS THE RIGHT
TO CROSS EXAMINE AND CONFRONT
HAS BEEN FOUND TO BE FUNDAMENTAL
TO OUR JURY SYSTEM TO DENY
OR DIMINISH THAT RIGHT NOT
ONLY DEPRIVES THE DEFENDANT
OF A FAIR TRIAL BUT CALLS
INTO QUESTION THE RELIABILITY
OF THE FACT FINDING PROCESS
DENNIS BEEN CONSIDERED ONE OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL GUARANTEES OF
LIFE AND LIBERTY ON THIS
IS A SLIPPERY SLOPE TODAY
ON THERE SAYING THAT THE
VICTIMS ADULT VICTIMS OF
STALKING NEED SPECIAL PROTECTION
TOMORROW IT WILL BE THE ADULT
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
THE NEXT DATE IT WILL BE THE
ADULT VICTIMS OF ROBBERY THE
ADULT VICTIMS OF ANY KIND OF
ASSAULT CRIME IS TRAUMATIC
AND SURVIVORS TO FEEL VICTIMIZED
BUT WE CANNOT TRADE OUR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS FOR THAT
AND AND MOREOVER -- EVIDENCE
CODE SECTION SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
ALREADY PROVIDES JUDGES WITH
THE AUTHORITY TO NEED TO USE
A NUMBER OF MEASURES TO CONTROL
THEIR COURTROOMS AND THEY'RE NOT
REACTIVE THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
MERELY HAS TO SAY WOULD YOU
PLEASE DO THESE THINGS AND
THE JUDGE HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO DO WITH THEM ONE OF THEM
IS TO REQUIRE THE DEFENDANT
TO REMAIN SEATED DURING THE
PROCEEDINGS AND TO NOT AND TO
HELP A CERTAIN DISTANCE FROM
THE WITNESS SO IN OTHER WORDS
IF I WERE THE DEFENDANT THE
JUDGE COULD ORDER ME NOT TO
APPROACH ANY CLOSER TO THE
WITNESS THEN THE BAILIFF WHO
WAS SITTING OVER THERE AT
THAT SHARE THE ARM
AND OF COURSE IF THERE HAS
BEEN PRIOR DISRUPTION BY
THE DEFENDANT THE JUDGE COHEN
-- ACTUALLY TAKE AWAY THE
RIGHT TO CROSS EXAMINE AND
CONFRONT AND APPOINT COUNSEL
AND IF THERE IS DISRUPTIVE
COURT ROOM UPON ACTUAL
BEHAVIOR IN THE COURTROOM --
AS THE AUTHOR SAID THEN THE
JUDGE CAN REACT AND AT THAT
POINT TAKE AWAY THE DEFENDANT'S
RIGHT TO CROSS EXAMINE AND
CONFRONT AND APPOINT COUNSEL
ADDITIONALLY ON THE COURT
HAS THE AUTHORITY WITH
-- ANY ONE CROSS EXAMINING
BE A PRO PER OR A LAWYER
TO LIMIT REPETITIVE
QUESTIONING TO LIMIT
HARASSING QUESTIONS AND TO
TOTALLY CONTROL THE COURTROOM
I JUST WANT TO READ SOMETHING
THAT THE U. S. SUPREME COURT
HAS SAID AND MILAN MELENDEZ
DHEAS VERSUS THE NIGHT VERSUS
MASSACHUSETTS THE CONFRONTATION
CLAUSE MAY MAKE THE PROSECUTION
OF CRIMINALS MORE BURDENSOME
BUT THAT IS EQUALLY TRUE OF
THE RIGHT TO TRIAL BY JURY
AND THE PRIVILEGE AGAINST SELF
INCRIMINATION THE CONFRONTATION
CLAUSE LIKE THOSE OTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL BROCK
PROVISIONS IS BINDING AND WE
MAY NOT DISREGARD IT AT OUR
CONVENIENCE WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MIKE A DOCTOR OFF
AND THE STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
TODAY I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN REGRETFUL OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL WE UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S GOALS OF
PROTECTING SURVIVORS OF STOCKING
AND WE DO NOT WISH TO DIMINISH
THESE GOALS BUT THESE CONCERNS
MUST BE BALANCED AGAINST
THE RIGHTS OF THE DEFENDANTS
AND THE STATE'S INTEREST
AN ACCURATE FACT FINDING
THE US CONSTITUTION GUARANTEES
THAT IN ALL PRIVATE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS THE ACCUSED SHALL
ENJOY THE RIGHT TO BE CONFRONTED
WITH WITNESSES AGAINST THEM
THE RIGHT OF CONFRONTATION HAS
LONG BEEN CONSIDERED ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL GUARANTEES OF LIFE
AND LIBERTY THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT HAS NOTED THAT FACE TO
FACE CONFRONTATION ENHANCES THE
ACCURACY OF FACT FINDING BY
REDUCING THE RISK THAT A WITNESS
WILL WRONGFULLY IMPLICATE AN
INNOCENT PERSON AND THE COURT
HAS BEEN CLEAR THAT THIS RIGHT
SHOULD BE LIMITED ONLY IN NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THIS REASON
CALIFORNIA HAS HISTORICALLY
BEEN VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT
ENACTING LEGISLATION THAT COULD
UNDERMINE THE CRIMINAL FACT
FINDING PROCESS OR INADVERTENTLY
LEAD TO WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS
AB SEVENTEEN NINETIES BROAD
APPLICATION IS INCONSISTENT
WITH THIS PREVIOUS APPROACH
I'M
THE CURRENT STATUTE EXPLICITLY
LIMITS THE USE OF THE PROCEDURE
OF CLOSED CIRCUIT ARE TESTIMONY
TO CHILDREN WHO ARE THIRTEEN
YEARS OF AGE OR YOUNGER AND
EVEN THEN ONLY IN SPECIFIED
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN FACED
WITH THE PREVIOUS PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND THE STATUTE TO INCREASE
THE AGE TO EVEN FIFTEEN THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SPECIFICALLY
REJECTED THE PROPOSAL AND
INSTEAD DREW THE LINE AT
THIRTEEN DETERMINING THAT AGE
TO BE THE APPROPRIATE AGE AT
WHICH TO LIMIT THE STATUTE
IN CONTRAST THIS BILL TODAY
WOULD EXPAND TO ANY AGE
NOTABLY THE LINE OF THIRTEEN
APPEARS IN MULTIPLE STATUTES
THE STATE HAVING CHOSEN TIME
AND TIME AGAIN TO TREAT CHILDREN
DIFFERENTLY AS MY COLLEAGUE
HAS SAID FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
AND WOULD URGE YOU TO VOTE
NOW THANK YOU THANK YOU RT
ANYMORE WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION
C. NINE BROKE OUT GO TO THE
PHONE LINE EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS
COULD YOU OPEN UP LINE FOR A AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY SIR ABOUT THIS
YES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
THAT IS ONE ZERO
I HAVE NO ONE IN Q. LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE SOMEONE IN OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM GOOD MORNING KALRA
RON REYES ON BEHALF THE JDC
PACIFIC GIVE ALL DEFENDER
CENTER AND OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU -- WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR COMMENTS MISTER CORK
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE ACLU
-- THE PERSON --
TESTIFYING FOR THE BILL
SAID THAT YOU CAN ONLY GET
THIS PROTECTION OF REMOTE
TESTIMONY IF THERE'S CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE OF THAT
THE PERSON WOULD BE HARMED
-- IS THAT THE WAY YOU
READ THE BILL AND IF SO
WHY DO YOU OBJECT TO THAT
-- I DO READ THE BILL AS
PROVIDING -- IT AS
A CASE BY CASE ANALYSIS
WHICH OF COURSE IS AN
APPROPRIATE APPROACH
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL IS TOO
BROAD IN ITS APPLICATION AS
MY COLLEAGUE SAID WHERE THIS
HAS BEEN CONSIDERED BEFORE
IT HAS BEEN FOR CHILDREN WHO
POSE A PARTICULAR VULNERABILITY
-- IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND FACED PARTICULAR HARMS AND
HAVING TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON THIS BILL IS DIFFERENT
THAN THESE PREVIOUS APPROACHES
AND THAT IT WOULD EXPAND
THIS PROCEDURE TO PEOPLE OF
ANY AGE AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
SAID THERE IS CONCERN THAT
THIS WILL OPEN THE DOOR TO
ADDITIONAL EXPANSIONS WHEN THIS
IS A RIGHT THAT HAS BEEN VERY
CAREFULLY AND CAUTIOUSLY LIMITED
BY THE COURTS AND BY THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THE PAST --
WELL I WELL TWO THINGS
ONE IS YEAH CLEARLY THE CASE
FOR CHILDREN IS DIFFERENT I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT IF THERE'S
CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE
THAT THE WITNESS WOULD BE HARMED
-- BY GIVING IN PERSON TESTIMONY
-- ISN'T THAT A REASON TO
ALLOW THEM TO TESTIFY REMOTELY
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK THE
ANSWER IS NO -- THE CRIMINAL
PROCESS IS VERY DIFFICULT IT
IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR WITNESSES
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
SURVIVORS IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
FOR DEFENDANTS AND NOT AS PART
OF THE NATURE OF OUR EXISTING
CRIMINAL SYSTEM -- AND WE CANNOT
SEEK TO A ROAD THIS ESTABLISHED
SYSTEM -- WHEN SURVIVORS
-- ARE ARE HARMED OR
FACE HARM BY HAVING TO TESTIFY
AND IT'S AGAIN NOT TO DIMINISH
THAT HARM NOT TO DISRESPECT
THE EXPERIENCE OF SURVIVORS
BUT THE RIGHTS OF DEFENDANTS
AND THIS LONG ESTABLISHED
RIGHT TO CONFRONTATION OF
ONE'S ACCUSERS -- OUTWEIGHS
THOSE -- THOSE HARMS
SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
WILDER'S -- NEEDS TO BE CLEAR
AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE YOUR
FEELING IS THAT THIS WOULD
REDUCE WELL AND I BELIEVE
YOU'RE RIGHT IT WHICH PROBABLY
SPREAD TO OTHER THINGS
BESIDES THIS BUT YOU'RE SAYING
THAT MOST WITNESSES --
ARE SHAKEN BY THE PROCESS
AND SO YOU COULD END UP WITH
MOST WITNESSES TESTIFIED
REMOTELY IS THAT THE CONCERN
-- I YOU KNOW I CAN'T SAY IF IF
MOST WITNESSES ARE ARE SHAKEN
BUT WE NEED WE DO KNOW THAT
THAT TESTIFYING EVEN TESTIFYING
IN COMMITTEE CAN BE IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT A DIFFICULT --
EXPERIENCE FOR LOTS OF PEOPLE
AND YET OUR CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM IS IS BUILT ON THIS
NOTION OF CONFRONTATION --
EVEN WHEN IT IS UNCOMFORTABLE
EVEN WHEN IT IS HARMFUL --
AND WHERE THERE HAVE BEEN
EXCEPTIONS IT HAS BEEN LIMITED
TO CHILDREN -- WHO ARE
AS WE ALL RIGHT NOW I UNDERSTAND
VULNERABLE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER BONTA
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FOR THIS BILL
I KNOW THAT IN THIS SPEND AT
CHALLENGING I MY SENSE IS THAT
-- THIS IS ACTUALLY VERY VERY
NARROWLY DEFINED -- AS
IT RELATES TO PRO PER DEFENDANTS
THERE HAS TO BE CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE AND -- THE
VERY NATURE OF THE OF THE
EDUCATE OF OF THE CRIME THAT'S
BEING ADJUDICATED HAS TO DO WITH
BEING IN THE PRESENCE OF THE
WITNESS -- I THINK IT'S IRONIC
QUITE FRANKLY THAT WE'RE HEARING
THIS IN COMMITTEE AT THE WEEK
OF OF THIS WEEK OF SEXUAL
LIKE LOOKING RECOGNIZING THEM
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND AND DENIM DAY
-- AND SO I THINK FOR ME
LIKE THE FACT THAT IS SO VERY
NARROWLY TAILORED MATTERS TO ME
-- IT ALSO MATTERS TO ME THAT
I DO THINK THAT A TECHNOLOGY
AND COVE IT HAS SHOWN US THAT
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE ENGAGED
IN FACT FINDING QUITE QUITE
ADMIRABLY AND -- WITH THE SKILL
OVER THE COURSE OF OF CODE
USING THE TECHNOLOGY REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO DO
SELL -- AND I DO HAVE A CONCERN
AS WE ALL SHOULD ABOUT THE
SIXTH AMENDMENT -- AND THE
CONFRONTATION CLAUSE TO I THINK
THE CASE FIVE DEMONSTRATES
AND KIND OF SHOWS THAT THERE
ARE TWO COMPONENTS OF THAT ONE
AROUND FACE TO FACE -- INNER
AT BEING ABLE TO CONFRONT FOR
A FACE TO FACE AND THE OTHER
AROUND CROSS EXAMINATION AND
-- AND I DO THINK THAT THERE
IS AN ALLOWANCE WITH REMOTE
-- IN THIS NARROWLY TAILORED WAY
TO STILL BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT --
THAT'S AT EXPERIENCE
OF FACE TO FACE EVEN THOUGH
IT IS REMOTE -- AS WE'VE
DEMONSTRATED THROUGHOUT
-- THROUGHOUT KOPET AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I
WANTED TO ADD THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FORWARD SOMETHING
THAT I THINK QUITE HONESTLY
WILL BE SOMETHING THAT THE
COURTS WILL HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AND -- AND WE
WILL LEARN MORE THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS BUT I THINK AT THIS
POINT I DO THINK THAT IT'S
A VALUABLE FOR OUR COMMUNITY
TO PASS IT THROUGH TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR BROADER IF YOU
COMMENTS CHRISTINE
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE FOR ALL THOSE WHO
ARE FOR THE SAKE OF DISCUSSION
I DO WANT TO DISCLOSE BY STATING
IN A WHILE THE CONFRONTATION
CLAUSE MANIFEST A PREFERENCE
FOR FACE TO FACE CONFRONTATION
IT IS A PREFERENCE I MUST
OCCASIONALLY GIVE WAY TO
CONSIDERATION A PUBLIC POLICY
THE NECESSITIES OF THE CASE
AND THE SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAID UNEQUIVOCALLY
THAT THE COMPETITION CLASSES
NOT PROVIDE AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT
TO FACE TO FACE CONFRONTATION
AGAIN THE QUESTION THAT WE
ARE POSING TODAY TO THIS
COMMITTEE THIS PROTECTING
SURVIVORS ARE CRIMINAL STOCKADE
AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
INTEREST IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
SECOND WHAT ELSE ONE THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT FOR ITS
SUPPORT DISCUSSION OF FOR
FOR FOR FOR THE CHAIR FOR ME
-- WE'VE HAD BEEN HAVING
DISCUSSION ABOUT ABOUT JUDGES
AND IT DOES SAY THAT JUDGES
UNDER'S EVIDENCE CODE TEXAS
SEVEN SIX FIVE HAVE CAN EXERCISE
CONTROL OVER INTERROGATION
OF WITNESSES TO PROTECT THEM
FROM UNDUE HARASSMENT OR
EMBARRASSMENT I I GET THE
FEELING THAT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S DON'T BELIEVE THE
JUDGES WILL PROTECT VICTIMS
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT'S
A LITTLE DISCONCERTING FOR ME
-- AND IF THAT'S THE PROBLEM
THE JUDGES AREN'T EXERCISING
-- THEIR ABILITY TO PROTECT
PEOPLE FROM BEING STALKING
BEING STOCKED DIDN'T THAT DO WE
NEED TO GET TO THE CORE OF THAT
AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE
NEED TO GET TO THE COURT THAT
-- AND -- ED THIS
OPENS IT UP SO THAT D.
A.'S CAN NOW USE THIS --
FOR ALL SORTS OF THINGS AND I'M
NOT REALLY REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH GIVING THEM THAT KIND OF
LATITUDE ALMOST OPENING IT UP TO
THREE STRIKES KIND OF --
UNDERSTANDING THAT IF SOMEBODY'S
AT HARM THAT WE JUST NEED TO
GO TO ZERO TO SIXTY IMMEDIATELY
JUDGES ARE THERE TO HELP
PROTECT TO WHEN I FIRST GOT
HERE IF YOU HAD SAID WE WOULD
NOT BE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE OF MANDATORY MINIMUMS
THREE STRIKES -- JUDGES WOULD
HAVE BEEN VERY VERY VERY
HARSH BUT NOT ONLY ON STOCKERS
BUT -- ALLEGED STALKERS THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN UNBELIEVABLY
HARSH ON THEM AND THEY WOULD
HAVE PROTECTED -- WITNESSES
IN WAYS THAT -- THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR RIGHT NOW THAT WE
WE WANT TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM
BEING STOCKED -- WHETHER IT'S
DENIM WE COULD NOT WE SHOULD
ALWAYS WE SHOULD ALWAYS PROTECT
PEOPLE FROM FROM BEING STOCKED
-- I THINK THERE'S ANOTHER
WAY AND WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION THAT'S RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS SUPPORT
BECAUSE THEY'RE DIRT EVIDENTLY
THE DA'S FONG I THINK THERE
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT'S
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS THAT
THAT THAT THEY DON'T BELIEVE
-- PEOPLE WILL BE IN STOCK
ARE BEING PROTECTED IN COURT
-- I'M READING THAT THERE IS
EVIDENCE THAT THERE IS THAT
IT IS AND IF IT ISN'T THEN
WE NEED TO GET TO THE CORE OF
IT WHICH IS WHAT OUR JUDGES
NOT DOING TO ULTIMATELY HELP
-- WITH THAT CALL THE ROLL
ON AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
BASS A MEMBER CERVANTES
THE MOTION IS TO PASS JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY
LACKEY HI BONTA BONTA
HI BRIAN BRIAN HI
CORK WORK NO SANTIAGO
SEYARTO C. R. TôI THAT
MEASURES LOCAL MEASURES UNCLE
NOW WE HAVE MISTER MERCER CHI
YES
I REMEMBER TWELVE
TWENTY THREE NINETY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR MISTER
SHERMAN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
LET ME START WITH WHAT I
BELIEVE WE ALL OR AT
LEAST MOST OF US AGREE ON
WHICH IS THAT WE WANT
PRE TRIAL DIVERSION PROGRAMS
TO BE EFFECTIVE WE WANT PRE
TRIAL DIVERSION PROGRAMS TO
WORK WE WANT THE DIVERSION
PROGRAMS THAT WILL ADDRESS
THE ROOT CAUSES OF CRIMES
WHETHER THEIR DRUG ADDICTION
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
POVERTY WE WANT
THESE COLLABORATIVE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAMS
TO WORK THE PROBLEM
IS THAT YOUR DRAWING
ON MY EXPERIENCE WHEN I
WAS IN THE CRIMINAL COURTS
IS THAT CURRENTLY
WITH CRIMES NOT ONLY
BEING TREATED CHARGED AS
MISDEMEANORS BUT THEY'RE
ROUTINELY CITED AND RELEASED
WITH -- NO CONSEQUENCES
THE CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS HAVE
NO INCENTIVE THEY HAVE NO
REASON TO PARTICIPATE IN
DIVERSION PROGRAMS I KNOW
AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR AND
AS A FORMER PUBLIC DEFENDER
THAT THE COMMON PRACTICE
INCOME RECORDS WHEN YOU
HAVE THE OPTION OF DIVERSION
IS FOR THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY TO
ADVISE THEIR CLIENT JUST
TAKE THE DEAL JUST DO THE
TIME BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU WENT BE SETTING UP THEY
WENT BE SETTING UP THEIR CLIENT
FOR THESE OFTEN YOU
KNOW ONEROUS TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AND SO THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO STRIKE
A BALANCE A BALANCE WITH
REPEAT RETELL OFFENDERS
TO ALLOW FOR THE AGGREGATION
OF THE REPEAT FAFF TO TREAT
REPEAT THEFT OFFENDERS
AS SERIOUS CRIMES
BUT NOT TO INCARCERATE THEM
TWO BUT TO GIVE THEM THE OPTION
OF THESE DIVERSION
PROGRAMS MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT JOB TRAINING
SO THAT THEY CAN GET
THE HELP THAT THEY NEED
WITH HERE -- THE IDEA TO SUPPLY
TEST FUND SUPPORTERS BILL --
IS STEVE MCCARTHY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN GOOD MORNING I'M STEVE
MCCARTHY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION SIERRA
IS A CO SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HELP HOTEL AND
LODGING ASSOCIATION SCHOOLS
ALSO SUPPORTED BY A COALITION
OF BUSINESS GROUPS REPRESENTING
A CROSS SECTION OF INDUSTRIES
DEMONSTRATING THE HARMFUL IMPACT
OF RETAIL THEFT NOT JUST ON
RETAILERS AND RETAIL EMPLOYEES
BUT ON OTHER BUSINESSES AS
WELL AND OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
AND COMMUNITIES OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS WE'VE MET WITH
NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS ON ALL SIDES
OF THESE ISSUES AND WITH THE
BENEFIT OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS WE
DEVELOP THIS PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE
IT'S A BALANCED APPROACH TO
RESTORING ENFORCEMENT OF SERIAL
THEFT LIKEWISE THIS BILL CREATES
SEEKS TO CREATE A MEANINGFUL
OFFRAMP FOR INDIVIDUALS CHARGED
THROUGH A FELONY THEFT DIVERSION
PROGRAM OUR GOAL IS THE SOMEONE
STATED IS NOT TO PUT MORE PEOPLE
IN JAIL BUT CHANGES ARE NEEDED
TO IMPROVE ENFORCEMENT AT OUR
STORES INTO INCENTIVIZE SERIAL
THIEVES TO ACCEPT PRE TRIAL
DIVERSION FORTUNATELY IN MANY
JURISDICTIONS AUTHORITIES ARE
SIMPLY CITING AND RELEASING
MISDEMEANOR SUSPECTS WITH
LIMITED PROSPECTS FOR REAL
CONSEQUENCES THIS IS REFLECTED
IN THE PERCEPTION OF THOSE WHO
COMMIT THESE STUFFS ACCORDING
TO A RECENT SURVEY BY THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR
SHOPLIFTING PREVENTION JUST
SIXTY TWO PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA
PARTICIPANTS IN THEIR THEFT
EDUCATION COURSES BELIEVE THEY
WOULD BE ARRESTED IF CAUGHT
STEALING AGAIN VERSUS EIGHTY
EIGHT PERCENT NATIONWIDE
THE DIVERSION ELEMENT OF
THIS BILL IS ESSENTIAL WE
WANT DIVERSION TO BE REAL AND
EFFECTIVE AND AS RETAILERS WE
ARE WILLING TO BE PART OF THAT
EFFORT YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE
NEXT WITNESS ABOUT HOW RETAILERS
SPONSORED TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE
HELPING FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS FIND A PATH TOWARD
EMPLOYMENT AND SUCCESS OUR
INDUSTRY IS COMMITTED TO FINDING
SOLUTIONS IN A COLLABORATIVE
WAY THAT BENEFIT THE COMMUNITIES
WE SERVE AS WELL AS OUR STORES
AND EMPLOYEES WE BELIEVE THE
FRAMEWORK OF THIS BILL IS A
PATH TOWARD SUCH A SOLUTION
THANK YOU MAY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
YET THANK YOU JULIE MULLIN
BASKETBALL AND THEY HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL
AND LODGING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DAY BUTLER
ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK A COALITION
OF LOCAL CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
ACROSS FOUR COUNTIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AND ROOM WILL
NOW GO TO THE -- AT&T PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE THAT'S ONE
ZERO AND FIRST WE WILL GO WITH
LINE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
BY THIS IS MEGAN
LANGSTON ARE LOOKING INWARD
FOUNDATION IN FACT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN HUMAN MARC ALLEGATION
HAS PARTNERED WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND A GREATER
MARGIN ANGELES COUNTY AREA
TO HELP INDIVIDUALS OVERCOME
EMPLOYMENT BARRIERS WITH OUR
CORE RIGHT THAT TRAINING PROGRAM
THAT HOLISTICALLY ADDRESSES
AND SUPPORT THEIR WHOLE PERSON
CARRYING MOST OF OUR CLIENTS
COME FROM GENERALLY SHOOTING
INTERNATIONALLY A MARGIN LIKE
JUSTICE AND BALK COMMUNITIES
WE UTILIZE THE NATIONAL RETAIL
FEDERATION FOUNDATION CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND FAILED CREDENTIAL
AS A PATHWAY FOR THEM TO
TRANSITION TO EMPLOYMENT
THE RETAIL AND RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY TEN COULD BE MORE
SECOND CHANCE FRIENDLY SO OUR
CLIENTS CAN QUICKLY FIGURE I
JOB AND PUT THEIR TRAINING TO
USE BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THEY
LEARNED THAT THERE IS MORE
OPPORTUNITIES OUT THERE BESIDES
THE LIFE OF CRIME AND POVERTY
ONE OF OUR MOST SUCCESSFUL AND
LONGSTANDING PARTNERSHIP IS WITH
GOODWILL SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
LA RICE PROGRAM WHAT ARE
PROJECTED TO GO THROUGH THREE
WEEKS OF CLASSROOM TRAINING GEN
THREE HUNDRED HOURS OF ON THE
JOB WORK EXPERIENCE TRAINING
AT A GOODWILL STORE AND I'D
LIKE TO SHARE THOSE POWERFUL
TICKET SIX WITH YOU NINETY TWO
PERCENT OF OUR PARTICIPANTS WHO
COMPLETE THE IN CLASS PORTION
OF THEIR CUSTOMER SERVICE AND
SALES TRAINING SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE PURCHASE AND
COMPLETE THEIR ON THE JOB
WORK EXPERIENCE TRAINING AT A
GOODWILL STORE EIGHTY PERCENT
OF THE PARTICIPANTS GET HIRED
BY GOOD WELL AND TWO PERCENT
OF THEM GET EMPLOYED AND A
SUPERVISOR OR MANAGEMENT LEVEL
POSITION I SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY NINETY BECAUSE THE BILL
ESTABLISHES AN EFFECTIVE RETAIL
THEFT DIVERSION PROGRAM WHICH
WILL HELP MORE INDIVIDUALS
FROM MARGINALIZED JUSTICE
INVOLVES COMMUNITIES BY TAKING
A RESTORATIVE JUSTICE APPROACH
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE WHOLE
PERSON CARE SUPPORT WITH
RESOURCES IN AWARENESS AROUND
ADDRESSING THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
AND ADDICTION ME PROVIDING
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
JOB TRAINING AND ACCESS TO
EDUCATION IN MY ROLE AS CHIEF
COMMUNITY OFFICER AT HUMAN
WORK FOUNDATION AND THE CHAIR
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
ACTION PARTNERSHIP ALLIANCE
I WORK TO INCREASE AWARENESS
AROUND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROVIDE ACCESS TO RESOURCES
THAT WILL HELP REDUCE RECIDIVISM
AND HEAL OUR COMMUNITIES
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND OBSERVANCE OF APRIL
SECOND CHANCE MONTH WHICH
WILL REAFFIRM YOUR COMMITMENT
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF HELPING
JUSTICE INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS AND
STRENGTHEN OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
CREDO AT HUMAN WORK FOUNDATION
OPTICAL THEIR OPPORTUNITIES
CURRENTLY I SEE THAT ONE
OF OUR OBSTACLES WE FACE IS
MAKING OUR COMMUNITY SAFER
AND STRONGER I THINK THIS
BILL IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
INTERVENE SUPPORT AND TRANSITION
INDIVIDUAL ONTO A BETTER PATH
THAT WILL HELP BREAK THE CYCLE
OF GENERATIONAL INCARCERATION
AND YOU'LL ARE MARGINALIZED AT
THE BALL COMMUNITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU
THIRTY NINE EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN FOR
THE COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF TORRENTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEGATIVE NINE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS REX W. HI MOM WE
HAVE TO GET BUILDING ENERGY
BUILDING OWNERS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AFTER CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND NEXT LINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO GERMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NATALIE ABOUT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
A MAN LINE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
ONE MOMENT THANK YOU TO
PLEASE HIT ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN NEXT WE HAVE LINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
KEEP DROPPING WE'LL GO BACK
TO I. NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS MATTHEW HARGROVE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION ALSO
ON BEHALF OF I. B. S. C. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS WILL GO
TO NINE NINE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE HIT LONDON ZERO
AGAIN NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
GETTY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT EXCELLENT THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YES HI COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NATALIE BALLOTS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE REPORT
NEXT HEADLINE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU SHOT
EARLY CHRISTIANITY CALLING
ON BEHALF THE LEFT FIELD IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THREE NINETY
NEXT HEADLINE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN
CAPITEC ALL THE CALIFORNIA
STATE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS FIFTEEN
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
MEMBERS -- IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE NINE THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINED
ONE OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MARLOWE
BOYLAND ON BEHALF OF THE
ROSEVILLE AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND I'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
ONE MOMENT HAVE APPEALED
TO THE I'M SORRY WOULD
YOU PLEASE RESTART
BUT MR HERE THIS IS BOB
TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE FIELD
-- NUMBER AND POWERED UP
JUNIOR A ORANGE COUNTY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU
AND THAT IS ALL WE HAD IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE BOTH SUPPORT I WE
JUST DID SUPPORT GO AHEAD
DAVID NELSON HERE DIRECTOR
PUBLIC POLICY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE REPRESENTING THE
OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
API -- SMALL AB I DON'T
BUSINESSES HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THAT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS MIKE A DOCTOR OFTEN
A STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE ACLU
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
TODAY I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
WE ARE REGRETFULLY OPPOSED
TO AB TWENTY THREE NINETY AND
LESS IT IS AMENDED TO REMOVE
THE PROVISIONS DEALING WITH
AGGREGATION OF PROPERTY THIS
COMMITTEE HAS CONSIDERED AND
RIGHTFULLY REJECTED MULTIPLE
BILLS OVER THE YEARS THAT SOUGHT
TO ALTER PROP FORTY SEVEN TO
ALLOW AGGREGATION OF PROPERTY
VALUES IN ORDER TO CHARGE
FELONIES THEN AS NOW THIS
PROPOSAL IS UNNECESSARY IT WILL
WASTE TAXPAYER DOLLARS IT WILL
EXACERBATE RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN OUR CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM
IT WILL LEAD TO FURTHER
OVERCROWDING OF OUR ALREADY
DANGEROUS JAILS AND IT WILL NOT
MAKE OUR COMMUNITY SAFER FOR
THE SAME REASONS THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD ONCE AGAIN REJECTED THIS
PROPOSAL THE SPONSORS HAVE
SAID THAT THEY DO NOT DESIRE
TO SEE MORE INDIVIDUAL SERVING
LONG TERM JAIL SENTENCES AND
THAT THEIR ONLY HOPE IS THAT
THIS BILL WILL DETER SERIAL
THEFT GET THE OPPOSITE OUTCOMES
ARE FAR MORE LIKELY DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE IN CALIFORNIA
SHOW THAT INCREASING THE PENAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR PETTY OFFENSES
TO INCLUDE FELONY CONVICTION
WILL NOT LEAD TO LESS BAFT
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT TO
THE EXTENT CRIMINAL LAWS DETER
CRIMES IT IS THE CERTAINTY
OF PUNISHMENT AS OPPOSED TO
THE SEVERITY OF PUNISHMENT
THAT SERVES A DETERRENT
VALUE RATHER AS THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE HAS FOUND
INCREASING PUNISHMENT IS NOT
ONLY INEFFECTIVE IT MAY ACTUALLY
EXACERBATE RECIDIVISM AND REDUCE
PUBLIC SAFETY FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE PROVISIONS
DEALING WITH AGGREGATION OF
PROPERTY THANK YOU YOU
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION I THINK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE BILL --
HOWEVER WE MUST SUPPOSE UNLESS
IT'S AMENDED TO DELETE THE
AGRIC CATION OF FEATURE
-- CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE SPOKEN
TWICE ABOUT PROP FORTY SEVEN
ON NOVEMBER FOURTH OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND MOST RECENTLY IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY WHEN
THEY REJECTED PROPOSITION TWENTY
-- IN FACT CRIME RATES
OF CONTRARY TO THE HIGHLY
PUBLICIZED TELEVISION NEWS HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN REDUCED SINCE
PROP FORTY SEVEN WAS ENACTED
AND I THINK THE PROBLEMS THAT
-- WE'RE ALL FACING IN TERMS
OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING ON TV
IS PROBABLY A LACK OF OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE AND
-- I DON'T THINK THAT WILL
BE SOLVED BY THIS LEGISLATION
ALL PROP FORTY SEVEN HAS
REDUCE RACIAL DISPARITIES --
I WOULD ECHO THIS DOCTOR ROSS
COMMENT ABOUT THE INCREASING
OF CRIME DOES NOT INCREASING
PUNISHMENT DOES NOT DETER
CRIME THE STUDIES HAVE FOUND
REPEATEDLY THAT THE DETERRENT
VALUE COMES FROM A SURE AND
RAPID RESPONSE ON PROP
FORTY SEVEN HAS REDUCE THE
PRISON POPULATION AND SAVED
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY ALONE
MUCH OF THAT MONEY HAS BEEN
REDIRECTED TO VICTIM SERVICES
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHICH WILL KEEP ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER --
FINALLY -- THIS BILL --
AMENDS PROP FORTY SEVEN IN
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE PROVISIONS
AND IT CANNOT BE AMENDED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IT WOULD HAVE
TO BE ACTED ON BY THE VOTERS
SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL UNLESS IT'S AMENDED TO
DELETE THE AGGREGATION --
PROVISIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU -- OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM AND OPPOSITION
SERVIC ME ON BEHALF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND RESPECT
PROPOSITIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
HE SUPPORTIVE FAN FROM THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THE MORNING RON RAY US WITH
THE PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER
CENTER AND OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THE NUMBER TO THE PHONE
LINES WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND FIRST WHO WILL GO TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI THIS IS JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA REGRETFULLY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE TO THE
FELONY AGGREGATION THANK YOU
SHE AND NEXT LINE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI THE FISHERY LUNCH
EVERYTHING GENTRY BRADLEY
-- EITHER SENATE AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE GOING
TO BE NONTRADITIONAL DISPEL
THANK YOU
AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. THEY WILL BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS MISTER EXACTLY
YEAH THERE ARE DEFINITELY
SOME VERY SUPPORTABLE ASPECTS
OF THIS THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL AND THIS BILL AND
I I DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING IT --
I ROUTE REGRETFULLY I'M NOT
IN A POSITION TO ACTUALLY
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE
FIRST OF ALL IT'S A VERY
HIGH BAR TO BE CATEGORIZED
AS WITH THE FELONY VERY
HIGH BAR NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS AN AGGREGATION OF
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH BUT
I DO IT WE TALKED ABOUT BALANCE
AND I DO BELIEVE THE DIVERSION
IS A VERY EFFECTIVE PATHWAY
FOR MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES --
BECAUSE IT IT DOES ADDRESS
A REFORM ATTITUDE AND GIVES
INCENTIVES AND REASONS TO BECOME
A MORE COMPLIANT PERSON BUT I I
DO BELIEVE THERE'S AN IMBALANCE
OF JUSTICE WHEN THE CONVENTION
WHEN A CONVICTION IS COMPLETELY
DISMISSED AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL AS I UNDERSTAND IT WILL --
WILL AFFORD THE OFFENDER AND
NOT ONLY CAN ARE THEY ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS -- THIS DIVERSION
BUT THIRD OF ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS DIVERSION ONCE A YEAR
I THINK THAT THAT'S WAY TOO
GENEROUS AND I I THINK THAT THAT
AVOIDS THE BALANCE OF JUSTICE
SO THERE THAT'S WHY I CAN'T
SUPPORT IT TODAY MISTER
MCKINNEY AT MIDNIGHT MAG RESPOND
I WOULD PREFER YOU DO
IN YOUR CLOTHES YOU KNOW
HOW MANY MORE YOU'LL
GET SO LET'S LET'S DO IT
THAT WAY GOOD
WELL YOU GET TO RESPOND
YOU MAY CLOSE YES THANK YOU
RIGHT ON TIME YOUR HEAD AT ME
YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO BE
PRAGMATIC HERE AND WE'RE TRYING
TO ACHIEVE WE'RE TRYING TO
MOVE THE BALL FORWARD RIGHT
NOW MISTER MERRETT MISDEMEANOR
DIVERSION PROGRAMS ARE NOT
WORKING THEY'RE NOT WORKING
BECAUSE THEY WOULD RATHER
PLEAD TO THE MISDEMEANOR DO THE
THREE TO FIVE DAYS IN JAIL AND
AND AND AND BE RELEASED --
SO THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE THE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT THEY'RE
NOT GETTING THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT AND AND AND THAT'S WHY
THIS YOU KNOW HAD YOU DID
THAT DIVERSIONS WILL ONLY WORK
IF THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES FOR
NOT PARTICIPATING AND AND THAT'S
WHY THIS AGGREGATION PORTION IS
IS NECESSARY I MEAN RESPECTFULLY
THE OPPOSITION ARGUMENT
SOUNDS LIKE THEY JUST CUT
AND PASTED ANY NOW THE LATEST
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN --
YOU KNOW ANTI PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN -- BUILD THIS BILL IS
IS SPECIFICALLY RECOGNIZE
TO TAKE THE AGGREGATION AND
TO DIRECT THEM TO DIVERSION
SO THAT THEY ARE NOT
INCARCERATED THEY ARE ASSUMING
THAT THEY WILL NOT COMPLY
WITH THE DIVERSION PROGRAM AND
THEIR AFTER BE INCARCERATED BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT I WOULD ASK I WOULD
REMIND -- MY COLLEAGUES THAT
THIS BILL IS ALSO SUPPORTED
BY PORAC AND AND THE STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION AS WELL
AS THE -- THE NUMEROUS --
RETAILERS GROCERS HOTEL
LODGING -- AND OTHER SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
TO DEAL WITH THIS REALITY
ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS AND SO
-- I ASK FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS JUST
TOO MUCH RETAIL THEFT OCCURRING
WE'RE TRYING TO BE PRAGMATIC
TO ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES IN
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ALBERT
BOB SO WE WE'VE
OBVIOUSLY SEEN SEVERAL BILLS
ARE PROP FORTY SEVEN AND --
-- JUST THIS WHOLE CONCEPT
OF AGGREGATION SEEMS TO BE TO
THE MAIN IMPETUS CIVIL A LOT
OF THEM WHICH DISK COMMITTEE
-- FOR THE MOST PART BY MAJORITY
VOTE HAS -- HAS HAS PUSHED
BACK ON WE HAVE PUT THROUGH
SOME BILLS THAT I THINK --
WILL HELP MOVE US IN A BETTER
DIRECTION NOT ONLY FOR RETAILERS
BUT EVEN FOR MY FRIENDS A
POOR ACTION TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND AND GET SOME THINGS
DONE AND WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
HAPPEN TO GO BACK TO KIND
OF -- YOU EITHER GO
INTO THIS PROGRAM OR I'M GONNA
LOCK YOU UP FOREVER KINDA
ATTITUDE BOB DIDN'T WORK BEFORE
THAT'S THAT'S OPEN TWENTY
THREE STRIKES AND MANDATORY
MINIMUMS WHICH WE DIDN'T HAVE
OUR L. A. TO RECRUIT WE DIDN'T
-- IT DIDN'T WORK WE NEVER
HAD THAT WE HAD FELLOW UNLESS
WHEN IT SPEAKS LET'S TRY THAT
AND SO YOU HAD YOUR LAST COMMENT
SO CHAIR RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE
VENTURE CALL THE ROLL AND AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY BY SEPTEMBER
MARTUCCI THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER CHEN SERRANO
LACKEY LACKEY NOT VOTING BONTA
BONTA NOW BRIAN BRIAN NO
CORK CORK NO SANTIAGO
SEYARTO C. R. TURNOUT
VOTING THAT I'M SORRY
THE MEASURE DOESN'T PASS
-- MISTER
PHILIP VIA -- TO WA
BOTH FRENCH AND SPANISH BE
APPROVED LA MOVE THE BELL
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST
I WANT TO THANK THE STAFF FOR
WORKING ON THE SECONDARY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AS MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS
ALSO WANTED THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS BILL THAT THIS IS STILL
A WORKING IN PROGRESS AND I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS JR FURTHER
REFINED THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
WILL INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND HELP A -- HELP BREAK
A CYCLE PRIMED THEM PROPERTY
BY ENSURING THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE SENTENCED ARE DUE TO
BE RELEASED FROM STATE PRISON
HAVE A TOOL AND SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE A REAL OPPORTUNITY A
REHABILITATION AND REDEMPTION
FOR FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE WHEN
THEY RETURNED HOME THE GOAL OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY YEARS
SIMPLY PREVENTING RECIDIVISM
FROM HELP FROM HAPPENING IN
THE FIRST PLACE OFTENTIMES WHEN
INDIVIDUALS ARE RELEASED THEY
DO THEY DO NOT HAVE EVERYTHING
TO LOOK FORWARD AND AND DO NOT
KNOW HOW TO NAVIGATE THE WORLD
THEY ARE RETURNING TO THIS
LEADS TO MANY TO GO BACK IN
THEIR OLD WAYS AND RE OFFEND
PUTTING THEM RIGHT BACK IN
PRISON AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
USES PROVIDE A PREVENTIVE
METHODS AND REDUCE IT REDUCING
RECIDIVISM IN MY CAREER I HAVE
SEEN HOW INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE
TO CHANGE OUR LIVES IF IF WE
TAKE THE TIME TO PROVIDE THE
TOOLS AND RESOURCES THEY NEEDED
TO TO BE SUCCESSFUL --
YOURS BACK I HAD A -- INDIVIDUAL
THAT THAT A FRIEND OF MINE
CALLED ME AND SAID HEY CROSS
I GOT THIS GUY THAT'S GETTING
OUT HE'S HE'S DONE SEVENTEEN
YEARS HE GOES YOU KNOW I REALLY
NEED YOU TO SEE IF YOU CAN
HELP THEM OUT SO I SAID YEAH
YOU'RE HAVING CALL ME SO THIS
CALL WAS FROM ME PICKING UP
WILL PERSON WAS IN PRISON --
I JUST I KIND OF JUST PICKED HIS
BRAIN AND SAYING HEY WHAT WOULD
YOU WANT TO DO I REALLY WANT
TO HELP YOU BUT WHAT I REALLY
DID WAS -- THIS IS A SMALL A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT I DID AT A
-- TRUCKING FACILITY -- BECAUSE
WE KNEW I KNEW IN MY DISTRICT --
THAT WE NEED TO TRUCKERS SO
I SAID I TELL YOU WHAT I GOT TO
SCHOOL FOR YOU ALL WILL ALL HELP
YOU THROUGH IT LONG AS YOU LET
ME HELP YOU SO YOU WENT THROUGH
A THIRTY DAY PROGRAM I'VE I'VE
I WALKED HIM THROUGH WORK NET
GOT IT PAID BUT I TOLD HIM I WAS
GONNA BE RIGHT THERE NEXT TO HIM
HELPING HIM OUT IF I DIDN'T WANT
HIM TO GO BACK INTO WHAT
HE'S DONE BEFORE OR BACK INTO
NEW HIS FIREMAN I WOULD IF
I REALLY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THERE WASN'T A WHOLE IS HAPPY --
THIS PERSON GRADUATED
ITS WORK TRUCKING COMPANY
-- NOW OWNS HIS OWN HOME
-- WE'VE NOW HE'S HELPED
TO OTHER FOLKS THAT WERE
IN PRISON THAT HE KNEW THEY
WERE COMING BACK IN MY IN MY
COMMUNITY DO THE SAME THING
THE OTHERS TO OTHER FOLKS
NOW THAT ARE THERE WORKING
FOR THE SAME TRUCKING COMPANY
-- THEY BOUGHT THEIR HOME
-- THE OTHER GUYS BY THE
CAR MY POINT IS THIS IS
THAT YOU KNOW I AS A AS A
AS THESE FOLKS GOT RELEASED
I I CANNOT HELP THEIR THEIR
THEIR HAND THROUGH THIS PROCESS
AND WHAT I WANT TO DO IS CHANGE
IS THAT IT IS SO HARD WHEN
YOU GET RELEASE HOW TO NAVIGATE
NOT EVERYONE HAS IS GOING TO
HAVE A PERSON THAT LIKE MYSELF
TO HELP HIM THROUGH WE DON'T
WANT TO REALLY DO IS MAKE SURE
WHEN THEY'RE BEFORE THEY GET
RELEASED BUT THEY'VE ALREADY
HAD CERTIFIED AND AND IN YOUR
DISTRICTS MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
IT MIGHT BE YOU KNOW WILDER OR
WHATEVER IT IS BUT WHAT WE
GOTTA DO MORE AS THEY'RE GETTING
RELEASED AND WE GOT TO MAKE
THE EXCITED ABOUT YOU KNOW
BEING RELEASED IN GETTING A
JOB AND HAVING THAT PERSON
TALKED ON HANDS ON BEFORE THEY
GET BEFORE THEY GET PLACED
IT'S IT THAT GAP IS VERY
HARD THAT GAP YOU CAN LOSE AN
INDIVIDUAL AND I'M JUST TRYING
TO CLOSE THAT GAP I'M TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THEY
RELEASED THEIR EXCITED THEY'RE
ALREADY TALKING TO THEIR THEIR
WHERE THEY'RE GONNA WORK WHO
THEY'RE GOING TO WORK WITH
THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT WILL SAY HEY
I I LOVE TO HELP FOLKS LIKE
THAT I HEAR THAT ALL DAY LONG
IN FACT THE THE THE THE THE
TRUCKING COMPANY WORK I WAS
REFERRING TO ALWAYS CALL ME
SAY CROSS CAN I NEED MORE
THOSE FOLKS HAVE BEEN THE BEST
BOOKS I'VE EVER HAD TO WORK WITH
SO LET ME THAT I ALSO WANT
I ALSO WANT TO -- CONTINUE
TO SHARE THE -- I'M ALSO MAYES
ON HOW OR OR OR COUNTIES
LIKE NORWAY HAVE TAKEN THIS
STEPS TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM
AND I BELIEVE WE CAN DO THE
SAME HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SEEKS
TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA ANTI
RECIDIVISM AND PUBLIC SAFETY ACT
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WILL
PROVIDE QUALIFY PARTICIPANTS
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO TURN
THEIR LIVES AROUND THE PILOT
PROGRAM WILL LEAN WILL LINK
SELECTED PARTICIPANTS WITH
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS INSIDE
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE PROVIDING
IT -- ENHANCE TRAINING CONNECT
INDIVIDUALS WITH EMPLOYERS
PRIOR TO BEING RELEASED AND
RESOURCES BEFORE LEAVING PRESS
THE GOAL THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM
IS TO REDUCE NOT ONLY A RATED
FOR OF RECIDIVISM BUT ALSO
PREVENT THE NEXT GENERATION
FROM ENTERING INTO THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WITH ME TODAY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS MATTHEW
EASLEY CHIEF LOBBYIST FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONS
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
THE STATE THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MATTHEW EASILY WITH CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY AND I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
PREVIOUSLY HAVING SUBMITTED
A LETTER WE ARE A VERY LATE
EDITION TO SUPPORT -- AND THERE
ARE WE KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
DETAILS STILL TO BE WORKED OUT
IN THE BILL BUT WE ALSO THINK
THERE'S REALLY A LOT TO LIKE
HERE AND WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES THIS BILL
CAN OFFER IS LONG PAST TIME
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TOOK A HARD LOOK AT HOW IT
DELIVERS REHABILITATIVE AND
VOCATIONAL TRAINING PROGRAMS
CDC ARE CURRENTLY OFFERS A LARGE
ASSORTMENT OF THESE PROGRAMS BUT
THEY'RE LACKING IN SEVERAL KEY
FACTORS THAT ARE CONTEMPLATED
BY THIS BILL PROGRAMS CURRENTLY
OFFERED LACK CLEAR GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES AND THE STATE
DOES NOT SEEM TO SUFFICIENTLY
EVALUATE WHETHER THESE PROGRAMS
OUR SUCCESSES THIS ONLY LEADS
TO THE CONTINUATION OF NEARLY
EVERY NEW PROGRAM ENDLESSLY
WHETHER OR NOT IT IS WORKING
THE NATURE OF THE PROPOSED
PILOT PROGRAM LENDS ITSELF
TO BE RE EVALUATED BECAUSE
IT'S TARGETED AT DELIVERING
REAL CHANGE AND REDUCTION
IN RECIDIVISM AND NOT JUST
ANOTHER PROGRAM FOR THE SAKE OF
COUNTING PARTICIPANTS EXISTING
VOCATIONAL TRAINING PROGRAMS
OFTEN HAVE NO CORRELATION TO
THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITIES TO
WHICH THE INMATES ARE GOING TO
BE RELEASED THIS RESULTS IN A
SUBSTANTIAL WASTE OF TIME AND
MONEY WHEN UPON RELEASE THERE
ARE NO AVAILABLE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EMPLOYMENT THIS OFTEN LEADS
TO THE FORMALLY INCARCERATED
TO TURN BACK TO CRIME WHEN
THEY HAVE NO OTHER OPTIONS AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY DIRECTLY
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY WORKING
WITH EMPLOYERS TO IDENTIFY THE
NEEDS TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
AND POTENTIAL POSITIONS OF
EMPLOYMENT THE SETTING IS
ALSO AN IMPORTANT FACTOR FOR
SUCCESSFUL REHABILITATION FOR
THOSE WILLING TO FOLLOW THE
RULES AND MAKE THE APPROPRIATE
CHANGES AND COMMITMENTS THEY
NEED TO BE SEPARATED FROM THE
GENERAL POPULATION EVEN WITH
THE APPROPRIATE MOTIVATIONS
AND INTENTIONS THE PRESSURES
FOUND FROM FELLOW INMATES CAN
BE OFTEN TO GREAT TO KEEP THIS
TO THE STRAIGHT AND NARROW
PRISON POLITICS CAN OFTEN BE
INESCAPABLE ONE PROGRAMS IN
HOUSING OR DELIVERED IN THE
SAME ENVIRONMENT AS THOSE WHO
HAVE NO INTENTION OF IMPROVING
THEMSELVES IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER THAT REGARDLESS OF
THE ENVIRONMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
THE SUCCESS OF ANY PROGRAM
DELIVERED IN PRISON THERE
NEEDS TO BE THE CONTACT THERE
NEEDS TO BE CONSEQUENCES FOR
FAILING TO FOLLOW THE RULES
AND ANYONE WHO CHOOSES TO BE
DISRUPTIVE CHALLENGING VIOLENT
OR THREATENING SHOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY TO BE REMOVED FROM
THE PROGRAM FOR THE SAKE OF
EVERYONE ELSE'S SUCCESS THE
CCPOA LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AS THE BILL
MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND WE REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU ENTER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS AT
LEAST OUR CITY KIND OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
APOLOGIES FOR THE LATE LETTER
SUBMISSION BUT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU
NOW GO TO PHONE LINES ARE
IN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AT THIS
TIME AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINDA WONDER
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY THANK YOU
AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. WOULD NOW GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION IN A
IN A ROW SEEING NONE
WILL GO TO THE LINES ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE
I HAVE NO IN ANY KILL RING
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MR LACKEY
YEAH I OBVIOUSLY WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY BECAUSE IT
HAS SO MUCH MERIT BUT I DO THINK
THAT THERE'S SOME -- AMENDMENTS
THAT I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER AS -- LIKE A LITTLE
STRONGER DEFINITION OF WHO
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE AND INELIGIBLE
-- FOR EXAMPLE WHEN CONSIDERING
VIOLENT OFFENDERS SEX OFFENDERS
ARE SUCH PEOPLE THE WITHIN THE
SCAPE RISK I WOULD HOPE THAT
THAT MIGHT BE PART OF THE --
THE RISK AND NEEDS ASSESSMENT
AS TO WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS THING TO AVOID THIS
IS JUST A LIKABLE INMATE
TYPE OF SITUATION SO --
YEAH BUT I'LL DEFINITELY BE
SUPPORTING IT BECAUSE IT --
IT SENDS THE RIGHT MESSAGE
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S
JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT THERE
ARE ASPECTS OF IT THAT ARE
VERY ALIGNED WITH --
THERE LEGISLATION THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS SEEN INCLUDING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT
THAT THIS YEAR AB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT AND TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
NUMBER BRIAN'S BELLA AND MINE
AS WELL -- AND APPRECIATE THAT I
DO I DO HOPE THAT YOU TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEYS -- AT COUNCIL
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE A
CLEAR SENSE OF WHO QUALIFIES FOR
THIS SO THAT IT ISN'T USED AS
SOMETHING THAT KIND OF SUPPORTS
WARDEN FAVORITISM AS THE
PRIMARY -- ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENT AND -- AND I
WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU
TO ENGAGE WITH MANY OF THAT
AMAZING REENTRY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY DOING
THIS WORK AND WHO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE PILOT IN A VERY SUCCESSFULLY
YEAH THAT'S ONE ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS THERE'S A WHOLE LOT
OF REENTRY PROVIDERS AROUND
THE STATE YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
GIVE SOME TECHNICAL GUIDANCE
AS YOU MOVE THIS THROUGH BUT
IT'S A GREAT BILL IT'S A GREAT
IDEA AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BRING TODAY THANKS
OKAY SEE YOU KNOW MORE YOU MAY
CLOSE STRICTLY ASPEN I'VE I'VE
THANK YOU CHAIRED A COMMITTEE I
CALLED ROLE ON AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY PASS A MEMBER OF THE
VALLAPUDUA THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI IS
THERE AYE LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN RYAN
I A QUIRK SANTIAGO
SEYARTO HI THERE TO I
THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
PLEASE READ OUR
READY WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
RIGHT GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE
WHICH SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE
DEFICIENCIES IN CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES
REYES BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR OFFICE AND RAISE
THE STANDARD OF CARE FOR
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FEDERAL
LAW REQUIRES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
MEDICAL CARE FOR INDIVIDUALS
IN THEIR CUSTODY IN CALIFORNIA
THE BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS WAS ESTABLISHED
IN ITS CURRENT FORM IN TWENTY
TWELVE TO PROVIDE STATEWIDE
COORDINATION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR LOCAL JUSTICE
SYSTEMS THE BSE C. IS TASKED
WITH DEVELOPING MINIMUM
STANDARDS FOR LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITIES AND INSPECTING AND
REPORTING ON FACILITY COMPLIANCE
BST SEE ALSO SET STANDARDS
FOR CORRECTIONAL TRAINING AND
ADMINISTERS FACILITIES FUNDING
AND SEVERAL GRANT PROGRAMS
FOR LOCAL CORRECTIONS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES IN TOTAL
THERE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES
IN CALIFORNIA THESE INCLUDE
JAILS WHICH CAN HOUSE PEOPLE
FOR SIGNIFICANT PERIODS OF
TIME WHILE SERVING SENTENCES
OR AWAITING TRIAL AND ARE
TYPICALLY OPERATED BY COUNTY
SHERIFF'S IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE INVESTIGATED
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND DISCOVERED
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR CUSTODY
DIED FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
MORE DEATHS PER AVERAGE DAILY
POPULATION SPENT ANY OTHER
CITY IN THE STATE LOCAL
ADVOCATES SUCH AS NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE COALITION
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
THE RACIAL JUSTICE COALITION OF
SAN DIEGO THE FAMILIES OF LOVED
ONES WHO LOST THEIR LIVES AND
OTHER GROUPS HAVE LONG CALLED
ATTENTION TO THE DANGEROUS AND
LARGE NUMBER OF SUICIDES AND
OTHER DEATHS PARTICULARLY IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY JAIL FACILITIES
BUT IMPORTANTLY MANY COUNTIES
AROUND THE STATE HAVE FACED
LITIGATION IN THE LAST DECADE
REGARDING THE CONDITIONS AND
COUNTY JAILS THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE ALONE HAS SUCCESSFULLY
LITIGATED CASES RELATED TO JAIL
CONDITIONS AND CONTRA COSTA
RIVERSIDE FRESNO SANTA BARBARA
SACRAMENTO SANTA CLARA AND SANTA
BARBARA BERNARDINO COUNTIES
MANY OF WHICH REVOLVED AROUND AN
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH CARE
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO STATE
AUDIT FINDINGS CONFIRMED THE
ALREADY EXTENSIVE PUBLIC RECORD
DOCUMENTING THE TRAGIC LOSS
OF LIVES SYSTEMIC FAILURES
AND INADEQUACY OF OVERSIGHT
THE AUDITOR NOTED THAT QUOTE
GIVEN THAT THE ANNUAL NUMBER
OF INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL
DESKS AND COUNTY JAILS
ACROSS THE STATE INCREASE
FROM TWO THOUSAND SIX TO TWENTY
TWENTY IMPROVING THE STATEWIDE
STANDARDS IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF INDIVIDUALS IN CUSTODY
IN ALL COUNTIES IN QUOTE
SOME OF THE SAN DIEGO
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT POLICY
DEFICIENCIES WERE THE RESULT
OF POOR STATEWIDE CORRECTION
STANDARDS DESIGNED BY THE B.
SEC INCLUDING A REGULATIONS
THAT ALLOW FOR INSUFFICIENT
HEALTH INTAKE EVALUATIONS AT
INTAKE INCONSISTENT FOLLOW UP
MEDICAL CARE INADEQUATE SAFETY
TAX AND UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN
RESPONSES TO MEDICAL EMERGENCIES
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE CO
DEFIES NUMEROUS RECOMMENDATIONS
TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
AND ALL DETENTION FACILITIES
OUTLINED BY THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE WILL
REQUIRE THE B. SEC TO DEVELOP
AND ADOPT REGULATIONS THAT
ALIGN WITH THE NATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES RELATED TO PERFORMANCE
INTAKE EVALUATIONS SAFETY
CHECKS AND REQUIRING ONGOING
CORRECTIONAL STAFF TRAINING
THIS BILL ALSO ADDS TO LICENSED
MEMBERS TO THE BOARD A LICENSE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER AND A
LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER AND WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE BY
PHONE IS TIFFANY WHITEN SENIOR
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ADVOCATE
AND PALOMA SERENA WHOSE
DAUGHTER DIED IN CUSTODY AT LAS
COLINAS DETENTION AND RE ENTRY
FACILITY AND TWENTY NINETEEN OF
NOVEMBER THANK YOU
OPERATING MAKE OPEN UP TO LISTEN
TO OUR THE TESTIMONY FROM TWO
WITNESSES FIVE MINUTES TOTAL
BOTH LANES ARE OPEN
RIGHT MODESTO CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE IN PARTICULAR ON BEHALF
OF OUR COUNTY JAIL EMPLOYEES
IN SAN DIEGO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHETHER
SOMETHING IN THIS IMPORTANT
BILL FORWARD WHICH IS CRITICAL
TO THE FUNDING COUNTY JAIL WE
SUPPORTED THE AUDIT REQUESTS AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND APPRECIATE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS PROVIDED
IN FEBRUARY AND THE WILLINGNESS
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
INTRODUCE A BILL TO ADDRESS
THESE NEEDS AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE WILL SAVE LIVES
SUPPORT WORKERS AND PUT THE
RIGHT INDIVIDUALS IN PLACE TO
SET APPROPRIATE STANDARDS AT THE
DSCC TO ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS INTAKE PROTOCOL TRAINING
FOR WORKERS AND SAFETY CHECKS
OUR MEMBERS KNOW FAR TOO WELL
THE DIFFICULTIES THAT I FACED
IN TAKE RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH
AND THAT AND THE DEATHS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED OVER THE YEARS
AT TIMES THEY HAVE BEEN TASKED
WITH MAKING MEDICAL DECISIONS
YET SOME ARE NOT HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS RATHER SWORN
OFFICERS THEY ARE NOT TRAINED
NOR EQUIPPED TO MAKE CERTAIN
DECISIONS AND AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE WILL HELP CHANGE THE
CURRENT PRACTICE THE ADDITION OF
A LICENSED HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
AND A LICENSED MENTAL HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER TO THE BSE SEE
AS LONG OVERDUE AND A SIMPLE
CHANGE WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
HELP REFORM IN JAIL CURRENTLY
THE BSE C. DOES NOT EXPLICITLY
REQUIRE THAT MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS PERFORM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SCREENINGS DURING THE
INTAKE PROCESS WHICH IS A BIT
SORT OF A WHICH IS A BIT SHORT
SIGHTED AND HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT
ON PEOPLE'S LIVES BY PUTTING
THE APPROPRIATE WORKERS IN
PLACE TO MAKE DECISIONS CONDUCT
INTAKE SCREENINGS AND PROVIDE
ROBUST TRAINING FOR CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS RELATED TO MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THE INTAKE
PROCESS WILL BE DRASTICALLY
IMPROVED NOT ONLY WILL AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY THREE HELPLESS ONE
JAILS IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AT ADDRESSING THE NEED
FOR PROPER STACKING SUPPORTS
WORKERS AND ULTIMATELY SAVE
LIVES FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
IN SUPPORT AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I THOUGHT THANK YOU
YES THANK YOU TERENCE COMMITTEE
MEMBER MY NAME IS PALOMA SERNA
IN NOVEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN
MY DAUGHTER HE CISTERNA DIED
AT THE JAIL IN SAN DIEGO
SHE DIED FROM DRUG WITHDRAWALS
AFTER BEING DENIED MEDICAL
TREATMENT BY THE DEPUTIES AND
NURSES FOR FIVE DAYS ON A
LEASES LAST DAY THE DEPUTIES
AND A NURSE WHO WATCHES HERSELF
FOR A SEIZURE SHE HIT HER HEAD
ON THE WALL COLLAPSED ONTO THE
GROUND THE JAIL STAFF TURNED
AROUND CLOSE THE DOOR AND ASKED
POLICE TO INTERCEPT DIE NOT
COMING BACK UNTIL AN HOUR LATER
LISA'S DEATH WAS PREVENTABLE
SHE BACK FROM HELP MULTIPLE
TIMES BUT SHE WAS REFUSED
BY ALL STAFF DEPUTIES NURSES
AND DOCTORS IN SAN DIEGO
THERE HAVE BEEN OVER A HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE DEATHS AND COUNTING
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
IF IT WASN'T FOR THE NORTH
COUNTY EQUAL EQUALITY AND
JUSTICE COALITION INITIATING
THE STABILIZE AND CUT THE
CAMPAIGN IN TWENTY TWENTY MY
DAUGHTER'S DEATH WOULD HAVE
NEVER BEEN HEARD OF WITH THE
RESULT OF THAT WE HAVE AT LEAST
ONE NURSE BEING CHARGED FOR
MY DAUGHTER'S DEATH I SPOKE
AT THE JOINT LEGISLATURE AUDIT
COMMITTEE IN JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REQUESTING FOR
A STATE AUDIT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY JAILS I NOW ASK
THIS COMMITTEE MEETING TODAY
PLEASE PRESS AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE SO THAT NO OTHER
FAMILY WILL GO THROUGH WHAT
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH THANK YOU
THANK YOU NOW GO TO THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAMP
OFF THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO -- HERE
IN SUPPORT AND PLEASED TO BE NOW
A CO SPONSOR ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MARCO GEORGE ABOUT HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
BANCFIRST HE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHEN THE WATER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY THIRD THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT LINE
WHAT WAS THAT IT
I KNOW WE HAVE WE
HAVE NEXT WE HAVE LINE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO DARWIN FISHMAN
AFTER THE RACIAL JUSTICE
COALITION OF SAN DIEGO
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY JUSTICE
COALITION WE SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION AND WE SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHATEVER'S
WORKED IT IN THE DEATH IN
CUSTODY IN SAN DIEGO THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
MY NAME IS YOUSSEF MILLER
WITH THE NORTH COUNTY EQUITY
AND JUST THE COALITION AND
THE RACIAL JUSTICE COALITION
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE SAVING
LIVES IN CUSTODY THANK YOU
AND THAT IS EVERYONE
I HAVE A CURE
OKAY --
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTING
QUESTION OPPOSITION
I'M SORRY OPPOSITION
CNN IN THE ROOM ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWO THREE FOUR THREE PLEASE
ONE NINE ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE AND ONE MOMENT
FOR FIRST LINE NUMBER
LINE ONE ZERO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MATURE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
WORKER THE ASIAN RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND THAT IS ALL
I HAVE BEEN Q. THANK YOU
DAHLE WORLD BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MISTER BRIAN I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I HAVE A LOVE ONE
WHO'S SPENT OVER FOUR HUNDRED
DAYS AND GEORGE BAILEY DETENTION
CENTER IN SAN DIEGO I VISITED
THERE MANY TIMES -- HER A LOT
OF STORIES -- I THINK RECENT
AUDITS HAVE REVEALED EVEN MORE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE WORKED
ON AND SO YOUR YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THE COALITION OF OTHER
SAN DIEGO LEGISLATORS COMING
TOGETHER TO TO LOOK AT THESE
ISSUES -- GIVES ME A LOT OF HOPE
AND I'M GREAT FOR THE BROUGHT
THIS TO THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
THE BILL SAID
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE AYE THERE IS
DEFINITELY A CRISIS OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE DYING
BEHIND BARS A JAIL
SENTENCE CANNOT BE A DEATH
SENTENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THESE PEOPLE IN CUSTODY
OR SOMEONE'S MOTHER FATHER
SISTER BROTHER DAUGHTER SON
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE
WILL BRING ABOUT THE NECESSARY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ENSURE THAT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS LAID OUT BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR ARE
IMPLEMENTED TO REDUCE SUICIDES
AND ENSURE THAT THOSE IN CUSTODY
IS ARE IN SAFE AND HUMANE
CONDITIONS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SHARES RECOMMENDING I'VE CALLED
CALDERON ON AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER
WEBER THE MISSION IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER AND THEIR IRAQI
PLAQUENIL BONTA HI BONTA
HI BRIAN BRIAN HI CORK
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I
SEE OUR TO SEE ACTONEL
IT MEASURES ARE
CALLED NEEDS ONE MORE
MR SANTIAGO
THANK
FAMOUS TRIBE MUCH APPRECIATE THE
THE TIME GIVEN TO US TO PRESENT
ON THIS -- AB TWENTY SIX
-- NINETY TWO WOULD CREATE THE
PRESUMPTION THAT WHEN A JUVENILE
COURT TERM EDUCATION THAT MEANS
WE'LL NO LONGER JUVENILE AND
FULFILL THE RESPONSIBILITIES
EDUCATE TO THEM BY A JUVENILE
COURT A JUDGE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DISMISS THE PERSON'S JUVENILE
RECORD LESS THAT DISMISSAL I
WOULD ENDANGER PUBLIC SAFETY
FROM THE SAY THAT AGAIN THE THE
JUDGE HAS DISCRETION IN A LESS
THAT AND UNLESS THAT WE TAKE
THIS OFF TO BE A LITTLE BIT
CLEARSIDE PODESTA FOLKS NOW I'M
SEEING FROM HEADS LOOKING AT ME
SOMEONE MAKE SURE OF THE CLEAR
I APOLOGIZE -- IT UNLESS THAT
UNLESS THAT DISMISSAL WOULD
ENDANGER PUBLIC SAFETY OR THERE
ARE SOME WHO ARE NOW SAY THAT
ONE MORE TIME BECAUSE OFTEN
TIMES PEOPLE SAY WELL WHAT IF
THIS PERSON GOES DOES THAT'S
WHAT THIS PERSON BECOMES A
THREAT UNLESS THAT DISMISSAL
WOULD ENDANGER THE PUBLIC SAFETY
THIRTY VERY CLEAR ABOUT THAT AND
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN A
JUVENILE ADJUDICATION -- AND
A CONVICTION THAT HAPPENS --
WHEN A PERSON IS AN ADULT THAT
MEANS EIGHTEEN OR OVER BECAUSE A
JUVENILE ADJUDICATION IS IS I'VE
COME TO LEARN OVER THE YEARS --
IT IS WHEN IT IS WHEN THEY DO
IT ALL GOES BEFORE COURT THERE'S
NO A JURY OF THEIR PEERS -- DID
YOU KNOW SYSTEM IS SUPPOSED TO
BE REHABILITATIVE BUT WHEN A
JUVENILE GOES BEFORE A COURT THE
COURT IN MY MIND IN MANY CASES
DETERMINE THE JUVENILES DONE
SOMETHING BECAUSE IT THE BURDEN
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO DEVELOP
THAT SAID -- THERE
IS NO REHABILITATIVE PROCESS
-- WHEN A PERSON IS INCARCERATED
I WANT TO STATE THAT BECAUSE
IT IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN IN
ADULT COURT ADULT COURT -- IS
IS IT WENT WHEN A PERSON GOES
TO TRIAL IT IS BEFORE THE COURT
IN IT IS DETERMINED BY IT BY A
JURY OF THEIR PEERS SO AGENTS
SO A PERSON HAS THE ABILITY TO
PRESENT INFORMATION AND MAKE
THE CASE TO A JURY OF THEIR
PEERS NOW WE MAY HAVE A DETAILS
OPTICAL DIFFERENCES ON HOW WE
VIEW THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
BUT THOSE ARE FACTS WHAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE IS THAT WHEN
A INDIVIDUAL -- IN AND AND
IS PRODUCTIVE AND I'M A STATE
AGAIN IS NO LONGER A DANGER
TO PUBLIC SAFETY THE DATA JUDY
CATION COULD BE -- COULD BE
REMOVED AND AND THAT GOES A LONG
WAYS -- IT ALLOWS A PERSON TO
POTENTIALLY LIST IN THE ARMY
-- TEAM -- IT A USEFUL EMPLOYEE
GAIN -- AND EMPLOYMENT -- OUT
OF STATE OR FACILITIES THAT
REQUIRE A FEDERAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS OR SECURE OPC --
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSES NOW SOME
PEOPLE HAVE ARGUED WELL YOU
KNOW YOU CAN SEAL A RECORD TO
THE CEILING THE RECORD ONLY
APPLIES TO CALIFORNIA SO IF
YOU WERE TO SEAL A RECORD --
YOU YOU COULD STILL GO TO SAY
NEVADA AND HAVE THIS -- SHOW
UP -- BUT I WE THINK THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
ABILITY TO CLEAN ONE'S RECORDS
IF THEY A PRODUCTIVE MEMBER
OF SOCIETY IS ONE THAT SHOULD
BE GRANTED THEM BECAUSE THEY
WANTED BECAUSE WE WANT THAT
PERSON TO LIVE ITS LIFE -- --
FULFILLED AND IN HAVING THAT THE
COURT -- THAT CASE AGAINST
THEM WHEN THEY WERE A JUVENILE
HAS HUGE DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS
-- IN A PERSON'S LIFE AND AGAIN
I WANTED I WANT TO SAY THAT IF
IT IF THE JUDGE HAS DISCRETION
AND WE DON'T TAKE THAT AWAY
-- DID DID TO DO NOW DISMISSAL
IF IT ENDANGERS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY PHONE TAKE THAT OFF
THE TABLE FOR FOLKS WHO
MAY HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT THAT
-- IN I HAVE TO WITNESSES
-- -- MIGUEL GARCIA
FROM ANTI RACISM COALITION AND
JONATHAN LAVA FROM THE PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER THANK
YOU I THINK I POINTED THE WRONG
DIRECTION WHEN I DID THAT SO
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS YOU LOOKING
DOWN GET THE NAMES RIGHT THANK
MISTER GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MIGUEL I HAS GOT SCEA I'M A
YOU'VE JUST A SPECIALIST WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND A CO SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN THE TEEN I
BECAME A WARD OF THE COURT OF
CALIFORNIA HAS SPENT TIME IN
CáC IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
A WHILE AT THESE INSTITUTIONS
I WAS HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE IMPACT OF MY
ACTIONS MADE UPON MY COMMUNITY
AND MY FAMILY FURTHERMORE
WHILE I WAS INCARCERATED I TOOK
MANY VOCATIONAL AND COLLEGE
COURSES TO PREPARE ME AS A
TRANSITION HOME IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FOURTEEN SINCE MY RELEASE
I'VE OBTAINED THREE ASSOCIATE
DEGREES AND A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
FROM UC RIVERSIDE AND I BECAME
A FATHER TO TWO BEAUTIFUL
DAUGHTERS NOW A BRAND NEW
HOMEOWNER MOST RECENTLY I WAS
APPOINTED AS A BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE BOARD OF STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS BE SEC THAT BEING
SAID MY REENTRY WITH CHALLENGING
HOWEVER IT DID NOT COMPARE TO
THE DIFFICULTIES ASSOCIATED
WITH MY JUVENILE RECORD
BEING ASSESSABLE TO EMPLOYERS
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
PRIVATE COMPANIES ESPECIALLY
THOSE OUT OF STATE I HAVE BEEN
SKEPTICAL AND MAKE MULTIPLE
SITUATIONS ABOUT WHETHER I
SHOULD ANSWER YES OR NO --
TWO QUESTIONS CONCERNING
MY JUVENILE BACKGROUND EVEN
THOUGH I HAVE DEMONSTRATED
MY RESILIENCE AND ABILITY TO
SUCCEED AS I HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO NAVIGATE MY TRANSITION INTO
ADULTHOOD CURRENTLY EXISTING
RECORD SETTING LAWS ARE LIMITED
TO THE RELIEF THEY PROVIDE
TO INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS MYSELF
AND PRESENT CHALLENGES AROUND
REENTRY FURTHERMORE THE CEILING
AND REALLY FLIES RELIEF LAWS
ONLY APPLY TO CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES AND DO NOT EXTEND
TO FEDERAL AGENCIES OR OTHER
STATES AS A RESULT I AM LIMITED
TO THE OPPORTUNITIES OUTSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA SUCH AS LAW
SCHOOLS AND OTHER GOOD PAYING
JOBS REQUIRING STRINGENT FBI
BACKGROUND CHECKS AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY NINE WILL HELP ALLEVIATE
THESE LIMITATIONS ALLOW ME
TO EXPLORE BETTER EDUCATIONAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO
PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY FOR THESE REASONS
AND MORE I URGE THE COMMITTEE
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME'S JOHN OF THE LAW BUT
I'M TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
THE PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER
CENTER WHICH IS THE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
NINE WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND FRESH LIFELINES
FOR YOUTH OR SPONSOR PARTNERSHIP
IS BASED ON THE IDEA THE YOUTH
EXITING THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM DESERVE A CHANCE TO
FULLY SEPARATE THEMSELVES FROM
THE COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES OF
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT BY HELPING
TO FACILITATE THE DISMISSAL OF
JUVENILE COURT PETITIONS WHEN
YOU FOR EXITING PROBATION THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW JUSTICE IMPACTED
YOUTH TO FULLY ACCESS FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES UNFORTUNATELY
UNDER CURRENT LAW EVEN IF THE
YOUTHS RECORDS HAVE BEEN SEALED
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES THAT REMAIN
JUVENILE ADJUDICATIONS MAY HARM
A NON CITIZEN CALIFORNIA YOUTH
WHO IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE LAWFUL
IMMIGRATION STATUS LIKE DR
GOOGLE EDUCATIONS ARE A BARRIER
TO ENTERING THE MILITARY AND
OBTAINING FEDERAL EMPLOYMENT
YOUTH APPLYING TO JOBS OR
EMPLOYMENT LICENSES IN OTHER
STATES FACE BARRIERS BECAUSE
OTHER STATES MAY NOT FULLY
RECOGNIZE CALIFORNIA RECORD
SEALING A DISMISSAL PROVIDES
THE STRONGEST PROTECTION AGAINST
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINE CREATES
A PRESUMPTION THE JUVENILE
ADJUDICATION SHOULD BE DISMISSED
WHEN A YOUTH EXITS PROBATION
UNLESS DISMISSAL OF THE PETITION
IT WOULD ENDANGER PUBLIC SAFETY
THE DEFINITION OF ENDANGER
PUBLIC SAFETY IS EXACTLY THE
DEFINITION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
JUST ADOPTED LAST YEAR WHEN IT
ENACTED SENATE BILL EIGHTY ONE
WHICH AMENDED THE ADULT JUVENILE
-- SKEWS ME THE ADULT DISMISSAL
STATURE IF A JUVENILE JUDGE
DETERMINES THAT DISMISSAL IS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
THE PRESUMPTION WILL NOT APPLY
THE JUDGE WILL NOT DISMISS THE
CASE AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
NINE ALSO PROVIDES IMPORTANT
GUIDANCE TO JUDGES ABOUT HOW
TO EXERCISE THE DISCRETION TO
DISMISS A JUVENILE PETITION IN
THE INTERESTS OF JUSTICE ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY THE LEGISLATURE
AMENDED THE ADULT DISMISSAL
STATUTE LAST YEAR IS BECAUSE
THE LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZE THAT
GIVING GUIDANCE TO JUDGES HOPES
TO REDUCE THE VERY PROFOUND
DISCREPANCIES AND DISPARITIES
IN JUDICIAL DECISION MAKING THAT
OCCUR FROM JUDGE TO JUDGE AND
FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY NINE ACCOMPLISHES
THIS VERY SAME GOAL FOR JUVENILE
COURT WE HOPE THESE PRINCIPLES
-- IN THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORT AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES
TO SUPPORT THEIR IN ROOM
GOOD AFTERNOON CALLING FORD WITH
FRESH LIFELINES FOR USE PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
BILL SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT
GOOD AFTERNOON RUN RIGHT
YES AND HERE'S A LIST OF
SUPPORTERS FOR THIS BILL THE
ASIAN LOS ANGELES DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ASIAN
PRISONER SUPPORT COMMITTEE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE YOUTH JUSTICE
CONGREGATION ORGANIZE FOR
PROPHETIC ENGAGEMENT FREEDOM FOR
YOU FRESNO FOR U. S. U. NEEDLES
IMMIGRATION LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH JUVENILE LAWCENTER LAW
PROJECT OF LOS ANGELES M. I.
L. P. A. NATIONAL INSTITUTE
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
NATIONAL JUVENILE JUSTICE
NETWORK PRIVATE DEFENDER
PROGRAM SAN MATTEO COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE SANTA CRUZ
VERIO SEE NEEDLES SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA THE GOLF CENTER
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
UC BERKELEY UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
INITIATIVE UC LOS ANGELES
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS SCHOLARS
INITIATIVE UC SAN DIEGO YOU
FORWARD AND YOU'LL TO LAW
CENTER THANK YOU THANK YOU
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU IS A BARGAIN
ST FROM THE ELEVATOR
CENTRE IN STRONG SUPPORT
SERAPEUM HAVE INITIATE JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NO GO TO PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
AND FIRST WE'LL GO WITH MINE
ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINDA WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY NINE THANK YOU
Q. AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU ANOTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SEEN NONE IN THE ROOM
WITNESSES OPPOSITION WE'RE
NOT GO TO THE PHONE LINES AT&T
OPERATOR TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO SIX
TWO NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
THAT IS ONE NINE ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE
I HAVE NO ONE IN CARE
THANK YOU AND I'LL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SEEN NONE
YOU MAY CLOSE THIS IS I THINK
YOU MISTER CHARLES BARKLEY
ASTRONOMICAL AND THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
-- NEED A MOTION THE SECOND
MOST SECOND
THAT'S CAREER --
THE CHAIRS RECOMMENDED IS
YOUR BUT GO AHEAD TAKE A VOTE
ON AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY LACKEY NEL BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN WORK
WORK I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I SEE OUR TELL THEIR TURN NOW
IT MEASURES ARE CALLED NEEDS
ONE MORE THANK YOU MR OKAY
WILL NOW GO TO THE VOTE ONLY
M. C. C. R. CHAU WHAT WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT ON ON HIS
AMENDMENTS WHICH IS ITEM TWENTY
SIX SO WE'LL GO IN ORDER SO
THERE --
OF DO IT FROM HERE MOVE
SEE OUR TOES WONDERFUL
THE POOR MAN THANK YOU
IT THOUGH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
I DON'T OVER TWENTY SIX AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE C. R. TOTAL
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER
HI LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN
WORK I WORK I SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO I SEYARTO
THEY ARE TELL I THAT MEASURE
NOT HAVE DIVERSION OUT PASSES
SO ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN WALDRON
THANK YOU SEE
MEASURES FOR VOTE ONLY AB
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN D.
PASSAGE APPROPRIATIONS JONES
SAWYER THOUGH JONES SAWYER
NO LACKEY LACKEY I BONTA
YEAH FONTANELLE BRIAN
CORK NO WORK NO
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO NOW SEYARTO
C. H. I. THAT MEASURE FAILS
FAILS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
AB FIFTEEN NINETY NINE KILEY
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER NOW
LACKEY LACKEY I BONTA
BONTA NO BRIAN
QUIRK WHICH WHAT WE TALKING
ABOUT AB FIFTEEN NINETY NINE BY
SEVEN OKAY THESE ARE OF ALTHOUGH
ONLY SIR QUIRK KNOWS SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO NO SEYARTO
THEY ARE TO I THAT MEASURE
FAILS I ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
IRWIN THIS MEASURES PROVIDE
ONLY JONES SAWYER HI JONES -- I
LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA
TWENTY MINUTES SIXTEEN
OUR AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN HI
CORK WORK I SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO I SEYARTO THEY
ARE T¡I THAT MEASURE PASSES
ADAM TWENTY SIX AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE
BRIAN BYE BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEYARTO BRIAN
WE ALREADY PASSED I'M
SORRY I'M CALLING JOSE
HAVE HOLIDAYS I'M CALLING
MISTER BRIAN BRIAN I'M
I AM TWENTY SEVEN AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBERED REGUS JONES
SAWYER CHEN SERRANO LACKEY
NO LATINO BONTA
BONTA NOW BRIAN BRIAN
NO CORK CORK NO SANTIAGO
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
THIS IS A VOTE ONLY ITEM
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE YES SIR
SANTIAGO NO SEYARTO
THEY ARE TURNOUT VOTING
THAT MEASURE FAILS
OKAY ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE AND WHEN
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
NO LACKEY LACKEY I BONTA
YEAH BONTA KNOW BRIAN
BRIAN NO CORK CORK NO SANTIAGO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT
B. NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE FOR
VOTE ONLY SANTIAGO NO SEYARTO
SEYARTO HI THAT MEASURE FAILS
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE
AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN MATHIS
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
NO LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA
YEAH BONTA KNOW BRIAN
BRIAN NOT VOTING
CORK CORK NO SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING SEYARTO
C. R. TWO I THAT MEASURE FAILS
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AB TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN CHOI FOR VOTE
ONLY JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
NO LACKEY LACKEY I BONTA
BONTA KNOW BRIAN BRIAN NO
CORK NO WORK NO SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO NO C. R. TWO C.
R. TWO I THAT MEASURE FAILS
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE AB
TWENTY THIRTY THREE SMITH
-- VOTE ONLY JONES SAWYER
SO JONES SAWYER NOW
LACKEY LACKEY I BONTA
NO BONTA KNOW BRIAN BRIAN
NO CORK CORK NO SANTIAGO
EXCUSE ME SAN DIEGO NOW
SEYARTO THEY ARE T¡I THAT
MEASURE FAILED ITEM A THIRTY
TWO A. B. -- TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FIVE JONES SAWYER
NO JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY LACKEY
HI BONTA BONTA KNOW BRIAN
BRIAN NO CORK CORK NO
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO NO SEYARTO
THERE ARE TWO EYES THAT MEASURE
FAILS ITEM THIRTY THREE AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY EIGHT WHAT
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
NO LACKEY LACKEY HI
BONTA BONTA KNOW BRIAN
RYAN NO CORK CORK NO
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO NO SEYARTO
THEY ARE T¡I THAT MEASURE FAILS
NEXT WE'LL GO TO ADD ONS
LIFTING OF CALLS ABOUT CHANGES
RIVEST SAID GO THROUGH ALL
THE MEASURES TAKEN UP TODAY
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
ADAM NUMBER ONE WAS ON
CONSENT I ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL SANTIAGO
NO NOT A PROBLEM SIR
WHICH LETTER FOR
ITEM NUMBER TWO I
I THINK YOU'RE NOT VOTING OKAY
-- WHAT'S THE NUMBER OF THAT
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY BY SOME MEMBERS CERVANTES
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING THAT MEASURE
FAILS I DON'T NUMBER
THREE TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY
SEMI MEMBER COOPER SANTIAGO
NO SAN DIEGO NOW
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL SANTIAGO
YES BY A FAMILY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES
I AM NUMBER FIVE IS ON CONSENT
ADAM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY TWO BY SOME
REMEMBER GRACE SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO HI ADAM NUMBER
SEVEN WITHOUT CONSENT
ADAM NUMBER EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO HI
THAT MEASURE PASSES ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY FIFTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I
ADAM NUMBER TEN WAS ON
CONSENT I DON'T NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
NINE MAIENSCHEIN SANTIAGO
SAN DIEGO I
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY THREE NINETY BY
SOME MEMBER MURATSUCHI
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO NOW
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN WAS
ON CONSENT ITEM FOURTEEN ON
CONSENT ITEM FIFTEEN ON CONSENT
ADAM SIXTEEN ON CONSENT ITEM
SEVENTEEN WITH ON CONSENT
I ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY BY BE
APPROVED LAW COURT WORK
I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
I ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL EXCUSE
ME CALL QUIRK HIGH COURT
HI THAT MEASURE NOW PASSES
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER
BONTA THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
THAT MEASURE NOW PASSES ITEM
TWENTY ONE WITH ON CONSENT
I AM TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY NINE BY SEVEN PM AGO
BRIAN THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL
BRIAN HI THAT MEASURE NOW PASSES
ITEM TWENTY THREE AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN FOR VOTE ONLY BRIAN
I AM TWENTY THREE AB
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN THIS
MEASURE IS FOR VOTE ONLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON
BRIAN NOW FOR
ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
FIFTEEN NINETY NINE BY
SEVEN MEMBER KILEY BRIAN
BRIAN NOW FOR
AND THAT'S IT FOR TO PRESS
TODAY IF THEY WERE RIGHT
MISTER CLARK WOULD YOU BE SO
KIND AS TO A JOURNALIST YES
SO -- THIS CONCLUDES
THAT THIS IS FOR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE -- EVERYONE
HAS VOTED SO WE'RE
GOING TO END THE HEARING NOW
THANK YOU SIR ALL
RIGHT MY PLEASURE